foreign
you
thank you mr chairman thank you members
of the committee
for allowing me to introduce this
i have
i have to say that as
i've heard the expression i'm hoping
you'll agree that this is a no-brainer
i've heard that probably four or five
times in the course of discussions with
folks talking about the bill so i'm
we'll see but my hope and is that this
is a pretty straightforward
bill the purpose of the bill
really is to ensure that there's a
robust plan and transition for students
with disabilities once
they prepare and ultimately leave public
schools so that they become independent
and civically engaged
community participants which
we all want whether we have children
with disabilities or not is certainly
the goal
and the whole point i think of our
public schools and our school system
in is to ensure that we have
competent participants who are actively
engaged in their communities through
whatever
means that may be
and certainly the individuals with
disabilities education act and section
are ways that we ensure that those
full educational opportunities are
available
for students with disabilities so
we've we've come a long way
with that but we have a long way to go
in my conversations with parents
as they talk about
their experience with special education
one of the most frustrating i shouldn't
say frustrating but anxiety producing
moments in that conversation as they
navigate a pretty complicated sometimes
intimidating system of special education
laws
is when their child is prepared to is
preparing to leave
the schools
there's a sense of anxiety and worry
that i think we all have
for our kids
when
we want to
have our kids exit public schools
and and be full independent participants
in their community and society
and there is
a strong sense of anxiety and worry when
parents reach this moment in time
there's
and in fact i would suggest it's
probably the most anxiety producing
moment in a child's special education
career if you will with with their
parents um what this bill does is it
leverages the pre-existing framework
that we have with under special
education law that's intended to
assist students with disabilities get
the education the educational
opportunity that they deserve
so that they are they can tap their full
potential once they leave school public
formal schooling that's the whole point
of public schools and schooling and
that's the whole point of special
education is that
kids transition out
and and
we have existing frameworks particularly
with the um individuals with
disabilities education act under the
requirement that there be transition
planning
for kids when they are preparing to
leave
public public schools and that there are
goals that need to be set among the iep
team with parents with the child with
the school officials to ensure that
once the doors open from the schoolhouse
and they've graduated
or left the system
that there is a web
and there is a network and there is some
plan
b behind
making sure that a child has their can
reach their fullest potential um
it would be a shame if we invest
so much in our formal schooling to
ensure that children get the equal
educational opportunity they deserve
in the k-12 setting if you will but then
the the the planning to go beyond isn't
sufficient enough or isn't robust enough
and that's part of the anxiety that i
hear from parents it's part of what i
see and that's what this bill intends
to address
include section 504 as part of this bill
because
that also captures and protects students
with disabilities although it does not
have a specific transition services
requirement like the iep structure
it seems to make if the whole goal is
equal educational access and opportunity
then it makes sense to include
children with with section 504
plans the there is a second part of the
bill um this basically two operative
parts part dealing with students with
disabilities and transition planning in
section 504
the second part of the bill would
relieve stu schools of that if they
already have
in school um
voter registration drives my
understanding in developing the bill is
that there are few not many that already
do this but the provision this bill
requires that they and i hope that they
would already be doing this if they're
offering that service in school that
they are providing the accommodations
that are required under 504 or a child's
iep in any in an event but this bill
makes it clear that they must um why
voting well
this this would only start a
conversation about registering to vote
and it leaves it to the team
be it a 504 team or iep team to
determine whether or not that makes
sense in that child's case and if so
they make a plan to to do that
voting obviously i think we could all
agree folks in this room um is of
critical importance um i imagine you
know we're here
as representatives by virtue of people
who have voted um it's a fundamental
right under the constitution um and so
it's we recognize that it's important
but but
there there's a symbolic and a
substantive value to it that relates to
the primary goal of special education
which is to to prepare a child to go out
in the world to be independent an active
civic participant in the in their
community and in the world and voting
does that and even the conversation
about registering to vote is an
empowering conversation for a child and
a parent at a table to talk about you
can make a difference there's a symbolic
nature of going in there and we all i
think
maybe we're political nerds we feel the
thrill of you know voting for an issue a
candidate whatever it is or a town
meeting or wherever it is so there is an
empowering feeling and i think for for
children with disabilities in particular
who have historically been marginalized
um and still face obstacles once they
leave school that is a particularly
powerful effect that even the
conversation about registering vote
never mind actually registering a vote
or actually voting
can can have and obviously there's the
substantive value to it um you know in
my town i think we'll probably get 10
percent will vote in in the march uh
election and that's a thousand people a
give or take of registered voters one
vote makes a difference we all know that
we've seen elections decided on on on
that so there's the the power to that
but research shows that people who
register to vote and people who vote are
are active and engaged in their
community they belong to civic groups
they um they care about who's on the
local board of trustees for the library
they are independent they are civic
minded and that is the exact purpose of
our public schools but also the exact
purpose and promise of the special
education laws that we have so
to me
uh ensuring that that conversation
happens at the iep table with the parent
and with the child
is is a gateway to leverage what we have
now and fully allow a child to to
to get the return on investment that we
make in a child through the k to 12
formal schooling once they leave school
because the whole goal is to have them
independent and self-sufficient and
active members of their community um and
and voting and registering a vote is is
a means that has a direct link to that
so that explains why why that is there
it's consistent entirely consistent i've
submitted written testimony
with
the congressional intent
which i've i've comment i've noted in my
written testimony of the idea the
individuals disability education act in
in terms of what we're trying to do so
in some that's what this bill does it
seeks really to leverage
what we have as an infrastructure to to
give students with disabilities make
good on the promise that we give them k
to 12 and make sure that that promise is
kept uh there's there's a network in
place for when those kids go on and
become citizens in our our communities
and with that i'll take any questions
thank you very much representative are
yes
representative litchfield thank you for
taking my question thank you for
bringing this forward i just wanted to
ask you what do you know what now right
now the standard is for children in the
regular education program as far as them
being taught the importance of voting
and how you go out and register to vote
i don't know i don't know thank you for
the question um i don't know the exact
i'm assuming that it it would occur i
don't know if there's a standard that
speaks to it if you know
specifically um i know we passed i think
was the last session of build regarding
the test for uh
civics uh education i believe which you
know makes what i'm doing pretty
consistent i think with what that that
is i don't i don't know per se i would
assume that
i know some schools i believe
do
offer some sort of in-service
voting registration drive i think it's
not many
so i assume that that conversation
happens
in that context if not in the context of
perhaps a social studies
class or history class
so i don't know if that answer i don't
know
yes
so i'm trying to think how to word it as
a question
i just see so often that we're carving
out different
different groups of students and it's
not equitable
and my question is would you be open to
this bill being for all students so we
teach all students the value of the i
understand we have a citizenship test i
don't remember how deep it goes
but would you be open to
we teach this to all students
yeah and i want i want to so so the
second operative provision of the bill
allows schools to do that and it gives
them that authority and local control to
do that so um you know if i
i think in terms of um you know i
understand the point about you know
carve outs if you will it's my term not
yours um
it seems that this particular student
population given given the history and
poor treatment public schools have had
with students with disabilities that
certainly deserving of that of sort of a
special treatment but
yeah i mean if schools want to do that
or if we were to insist that all schools
do that
um
yes that be agreeable and
um the only thing i would ask is that
and i would assume that this would be
uh
and i do codify it if this was to become
law is that the accommodations that a
child would need who is a student with
disabilities would be provided in that
process of registering to vote if they
if they're whatever it may be so yeah
thank you
further questions
i have one question for you uh in your
second portion of the bill here in roman
two
it speaks to all students on one or more
days each academic year whereas uh i
know in the district i have it's it's
taught in
civics class
at the that the high school level
you take civics just once while you're
in high school
so
it's being done but it's not being done
every year but every student is required
to have civics so it is being done for
all students
but this
is the way that this is worded would
that then eliminate the process that the
some of these districts have chosen to
do this
uh if we incorporate it for all students
as this says
does your bill kind of uh
re re-think or or have us rethink what's
going on with how curriculum is managed
locally in our districts
thanks for the question um
not necessarily i don't believe i i
think the two things could could exist
at the same at the sign at the same time
that the civics
instruction could occur as you're
describing it and a school could make uh
good on
roman two
in this bill uh and provide that for all
it may spark a conversation about um you
know how best to to proceed
um at the local level
if we were to do that would it not take
some changing of how you worded it in
um if we were to do
through the civics class that's taught
in the high school
potentially
potentially it could
if i'm understanding the question
correctly i think there's nothing that
prohibits
a civics class in addition to doing
what they would do here and that's
assuming that
the school uh chose that they were going
to go with operative with uh roman two
as opposed to sticking to roman one just
in the special education process so
potentially i suppose if we on a
case-by-case basis
thank you language further questions
representative nelson
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
if a special ed student is going through
the process for these extra years and
they are
very difficult
problem they're severely handicapped
what
how do you plan to work with those when
maybe they could benefit from something
from something else
that might be more beneficial for their
thank you for the question um
i think
that
um
as a matter of practice you know that
that the bill only requires that a
conversation happen at the at the iep
table with the parents the child and the
school officials about whether or not
registering
um to to to vote would be appropriate so
those case-by-case basis could be
handled there
but i think
in my view
i'm getting older
but having seen how much progress we've
made
removing barriers for children and
people with disabilities in a short time
i mean in the 1970s children with
disabilities were
wholesalely foreclosed from accessing a
public education so my hope
would be that with that in mind and we
have a lot more to do
uh no doubt um but but what my hope
would be that with that in mind that
those opportunities especially one
um so important as a fundamental right
to vote
um and that as empowering as that can be
for any of us um but particularly for
maybe
students
uh who who may not feel empowered and
and may be regular uh non-disabled
children who are
you know voting for the first time that
they feel empowered wow i can make a
difference but but with respect to
students with disabilities my hope is
that
um
that that it would be
recognize the significance of what
voting would be um and at that
conversation at that at that table with
with the players there
for the representative porter
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
i'm i'm a little confused now
the roman 2 section of your of the bill
talks about in-school voter registration
and that's a process that maybe the town
clerk comes in and registers students
it's not talking about a civics
class am i right in that or am i wrong
in that yes and i think thank you for
the question and the bill does not touch
a civic's curriculum or class or those
decisions there it just simply
would call for an in-school voter
registration not nothing in terms of the
specific content about about
civics or what that means
no so that's a separate issue but thank
you thank you for that question
representative cordelli
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative
um i'm just wondering about your intent
with lines 9 and 10 in roman 1
um
what decisions are you talking about
should be included in an iep plan
so in in the iep plan process there's
the prior to that in in the
section within that section but above
that sentence
it describes um
whether or not
bringing up the conversation about
whether or not registration would be an
appropriate goal and then the iep itself
has grids for transition services so
presumably if that was
determined to be a reasonable goal
for the child it would be in that and
typically in my experience it would
explain
what that meant so
you know
mom will take
this child to
town hall
and and register to vote within the next
year something along along lowe's
assuming
you know that that's what they determine
would be appropriate appropriate goal
so be codified in the plan itself
thank you for the question
further questions
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thank you thank you very much thank you
for allowing me to
testify like to call forward
liz
tenerelli
do you have a a button you can push
there when it comes on red you're out
here i'm on okay
thank you for this opportunity to
testify my name is liz tentarelli i'm
president of the non-partisan league of
women voters of new hampshire
and we have been working on improving
access to voting
empowering voters for the last 102 years
so i am here in support of this bill
my written testimony talks about some
specific things related to part two
and that is where a school holds an
in-person voter registration drive for
students
in the last few years some of these have
been held
a league member organized in conway
which is a regional school district and
actually had supervisors of the
checklist or town clerks
from several towns right on site that's
not easy to do you know we know that in
regional school districts another league
member who was a supervisor of the
checklist in nashua offered a drive
there
and recently a young person a student in
laconia
organized this
for the most part that doesn't happen so
even young people without disabilities
sometimes don't quite realize how they
have to register
what voting means what the procedures
are
that's particularly a problem for
students with some disabilities
for instance a blind student needs to
know that we do have
facilities at the polling place for
students with visual impairments
students who don't have driver's
licenses and that includes both students
with disabilities and those without for
economic reasons
need to know what they can do to get a
voter id
the non-driver voter id that applies
for that reason the league publishes a
lot of material both on its website and
in
specific brochures
to help people understand what the
process is
i think this is a wonderful bill
to include this in the iep planning for
students
with disabilities so they understand the
accommodations
that are available to them
so that the parents will understand
what those accommodations are and how
they can get that young person
registered
even if he or she can't drive
can't get to the the polls or to the
registration place
so for those reasons the league heartily
supports this
we know that young people are the least
likely group the 18 to 28 group is the
least likely to vote in this country
that's improving slightly over the over
the last
six years or so more of them are doing
it and i just want to be sure that
students with disabilities are included
in that group
of getting more interest in politics and
knowing how they can become active
members of it
i'd be glad to take questions if you
have any thank you very much liz
represent hobson
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question thank you for
testifying today i was just wondering if
you had tried any outreach to uh parents
of children with disabilities no we have
not not at this point we try to get
someone in the schools
to distribute our brochures our student
age specific brochures about how to
you can't just bring them to the schools
obviously there has to be somebody there
actively doing it so we try to make
contact with civics teachers for
instance
but no we have not so far reached out to
any specific
student
disabilities groups it's a good idea
though thank you for that
might be a
confidentiality issue associated with
that you're not going to get names no no
no i didn't i did not intend that i
meant that we provide materials that
they could then distribute to students
that's the way to do it yes further
questions
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you
good morning
sorry
my name is bonnie dunham i live in
merrimack new hampshire and i'm here in
support of this bill
it aligns with the purposes of idea
which one of which is to prepare
students with disabilities for
further employment further education in
in independent living which includes
community participation this includes
learning how to be a responsible adult
which of which voting is a big part
i d a requires the ieps of each student
as they get older beginning starting by
age 16
to include transition goals and the
services to accomplish those goals so
goal is to prepare that student for
adulthood
and when the student reaches the age of
17 so one year before they reach the age
of majority the iep has to include a
statement stating that the child has
been informed of what rights under idea
will transfer to them upon their
reaching the age of majority
discussing voter registration as an
appropriate community living and
citizenship training goal to be included
in the iep or 504 plan seems like a
logical companion to informing the
student of what special education rights
will transfer to them at age 18.
on a personal level i'm the parent of an
adult son with disabilities sean has
down syndrome and a mitochondrial
disorder
and
i know that voting is an important part
of his identity as a responsible adult
sean knows who doesn't vote children and
people who don't care and he knows that
he is neither of those people
when sean was born people with
disabilities were not expected to go to
school
they were not expected to get jobs or
contribute to their communities
he does he did go to school
he has a job he's had it for 20 years
since he finished school
and he takes the civic duties very
responsibly he volunteers he votes and
he recycles
we take careful steps to ensure that he
can make informed choices that means
reading candidates websites and campaign
campaign literature and he goes to
events and asks questions about things
that matter to him he's never missed
voting in an election even when he woke
up with pneumonia he insisted that he
had to vote before we went to the
hospital
we took sean to register when he turned
18 just as we did to his sister with his
sister but i know that not every parent
votes i also know that
parents sometimes have been
given the impression that their children
have such low abilities the culture of
low expectations that they may not even
consider that their student their child
would want to vote or be able to neither
of those are true
this bill treats students with
disabilities as responsible adults by
compelling the iep team which includes
the youth with a disability beginning by
age 16
to discuss the student registering to
vote and about how they would accomplish
that
it's a
great bill and i encourage you to
support it
thank you very much bonnie are there
questions from the committee
not seeing any hands thank you very much
good morning
i'm karen rosenberg i am the new policy
director at the disability rights center
prior to becoming the policy director i
represented students and parents of
students with disabilities in special
education matters and i'm here to
encourage you to support house bill 1594
which as you know would basically use
our existing iep and 504 infrastructure
to include a discussion about in
transition planning um about whether it
makes sense for a student to register to
vote
and
as bonnie mentioned the purpose of the
individuals with disabilities act idea
is to prepare our students to become
independent employed and fully engaged
citizens
the focus of idea is to educate our
students in the least restrictive
environment with their peers so that
they can be part of the school community
and part of the larger community
voting is essential to citizenship in
this country it is one of the privileges
we all enjoy
and it's one that it comes with some
responsibilities and so
using
the ied i um the iep process
and
the 504 meetings as an opportunity to
help further prepare students to be
civically engaged independent adults
makes a lot of sense
it would be great if our schools
would
include this kind of discussion in for
all of our students i think
representative litchfield you asked
about that i know from um it's been a
little while since my kids were in high
school they took civics i think it was
in ninth or tenth grade and um so they
weren't really close to being of age to
register one and also students with
disabilities may require some supports
that students without disabilities don't
require in terms of figuring out how to
register and maybe getting some support
to do that
so
yes it's important for all of our
students our job
is to our school's job is to prepare all
of our students to be productive
independent engaged adults um students
with disabilities may just need a little
bit of extra time and assistance with
that
and also just so you know a lot of
schools do this already
there are model materials that schools
use to
undergo transition planning for students
with disabilities and a lot of those
model materials include discussions
about
like a checklist have you discussed how
to get an id in states like ours that
requires identification to vote um have
you discussed voter registration so some
of those things are already in the
curriculum and in
materials that iep teams use this would
really standardize it and make sure that
all of our students with disabilities
have those discussions and are afforded
this opportunity so thank you for what i
hope will be your support of this bill
and i'm happy to take any questions you
might have thank you very much questions
do you have access to these model
materials that we you know maybe a best
practice that could be embedded within
our instruction at the high schools
right now so there are materials all
online in fact i think the depart u.s
department of education has a link to
materials on transition planning but um
the parent information center i believe
has a link to information on transition
planning i'd be happy to share some of
that with you if you want me to collate
it but there's so much there's a lot out
there that's okay i think i know that
our life skills teachers do a lot of
this but that's just one portion of the
iep whole process right so thank you
very much you're welcome any other
questions
thank you very much for your time and
the last pink card we have up here on
this board is kathleen
uh
sent
how do you see your last name you know i
i see c-i-n-t
and i a-v-e-y
okay welcome good morning
um
i'm kathleen cintavi from dover new
hampshire and i'm a lifelong educator
and i have sat in on many 504 and iep
plans
and i can tell you that they are very
complex with a lot involved in there
many of our iep and 504 students are
mainstream they are in regular education
classes as much as fits in with their
iep they may have an aid with them in
that class to help them to understand
what is going on
in that class so
they should be by and large exposed to
this
but do keep in mind there there is a
wide variety of disabilities
and
some students
because of their disability may actually
have a difficulty in truly understanding
the voting process and selecting the
person
who would best meet their particular
needs
but
part of voting is to register to vote
and
i think that as we're trying to
mainstream our students it is probably
in their best interest for them to do
this as the general population does this
by bringing in documentation
proof of residence a birth certificate a
picture id
there are a lot of opportunities to
register at city or town halls also on
the date of voting and i have registered
people in dover personally and i can
tell you that any help or support that
is needed
for anyone who comes in to register we
do that
for several years i helped to register
people for instance in a nursing home
who were at all various levels of
understanding and we helped each and
every one of them so in regards to
actually registering to vote i believe
that in general there is a lot of help
available there
but part of what we want all of our
students whether they have an iep a 504
plan or anything else we want them to
all learn rights and responsibilities
and how to practice them
and fortunately we also have parents to
help support this undertaking
and i just hesitate to see parental
rights further erode and give more and
more responsibility to our schools
teachers are quite overwhelmed very
often with all the responsibilities that
they have at present
and adding one more thing like this
and making it a requirement i'm not sure
is the best way
to go i would i would like us to make
sure if this does pass
that the parents understand their role
and all of this and their rights and
responsibilities and that here in new
hampshire
we remain
a state that
recognizes the rights responsibilities
not only of the child but of the parent
as well and we do not acquiesce to
giving
more and more responsibilities to our
schools
you know we lose control over what's
going on in our schools it's very hard
for instance in the city of dover the
public is not welcome in the school so
we couldn't even go in and visit a class
to see
what's going on in a civics class or
anything else so i think we need to
tread cautiously
as we approach
this bill thank you thank you very much
for your testimony are there further
questions from the committee
yes represent tanner
thank you and thank you for coming in
and for being an educator for a long
time that that's really a service to the
community i just am confused whether you
support this bill or you oppose this
bill um i am not supporting all the
parts of this bill
i do not support the second part of this
bill
i
believe that we need to let civic
responsibilities
be civic responsibility and not bring
thank you further questions from the
committee
not seeing any hands thank you very much
so that concludes our testimony for this
particular hearing we'll close the
hearing down mr chair yes i did check
the numbers and it was support 135 and
oppose 24.
thank you you're welcome
and as a reminder for all the the
numbers which are online they close at
the end of today not not at this moment
yeah
thank you so we'll open up the next
buddy
yes
you
we're going to go ahead with the next
hearing right now the this hearing is hb
prohibiting higher education
institutions receiving state funds from
requiring face mass and covert 19
vaccinations for attendance
and the bill has been put forward by
representation
uh peter is here well there he is right
in front of me
welcome i'm i'm ready mr chairman thank
you
good morning and thank you mr chairman
and members of the education committee
for the record my name is peter teroshan
i represent the
rockingham county district 14 which is
the towns of atkinson and blasto
i'm here today as the prime sponsor of
and i'm asking you to
consider passage of this legislation
what this bill does is prevent prohibits
higher education institutions
that take new hampshire taxpayer
funds
from requiring a coven 19 vaccination or
face mass for enrollment or attendance
so there's times that people enroll
in a university particularly these days
with technology where they may not even
have an in-person class or it may be a
small class where there's certainly
plenty of room for
instructors
to
exercise a six-foot
rule that we've come to know
very well the last couple of years
we we now have
data on the transmission of cover 19
particularly the delta and omnicron
variants
seems that there is a very similar
transmission rate now between the
vaccinated and non-vaccinated uh
folks
in fact i do some part-time work for a
retail
company down in salem
we're about
95 percent of the people
probably even higher than that or
vaccinated in the facility
and
recently somebody this was back in
november
was out because they found out they
tested positive
for covid
everybody
there
with only one exception whether they
were vaccinated not vaccinated
came down with covert
the only person that didn't
did have covert
um
initially in 2020
and
he did not
get
virus how was the outcome for people it
was all over the place but there were
many that weren't vaccinated that
actually um
recovered quicker than those that were
so there didn't seem to be an
appreciable difference one will never
know but anyway
i only mention that because we do have
data now and
we do um there are
you know options that schools can use
um
with six foot spacing this this
legislation doesn't prohibit them from
putting up shields or barriers
uh and um again there's times that you
are taking a remote class you're
enrolled but you're not necessarily in a
classroom closer than six feet to other
students
one of my concerns with the with the way
things are done currently is that i
believe that by requiring uh
particularly a
vaccine i'll use the word passport to
enroll and attend is you're singling out
you're creating a class you're dividing
people
um it doesn't take into consideration uh
what
the
admissions people usually look at
the students
background and so forth it simply says
it doesn't matter none of that matters
if you're not vaccinated you can't
enroll so that that's concerning i
believe it's
discriminatory
and also there are students who are
elected to go to in to other
universities in other states where they
don't do this
and they leave it up to individual
choice which at the end of the day i
believe it should be
and so there's an economic
potential economic loss there as well
from students that we end up uh losing
the other in an important issue here is
that
the vaccine
you know how
much have we seen on the various
vaccines and their effectiveness that
was
i'll use the word promised it ended up
being the case so there's a lot we still
don't know
and
the so-called experts have changed their
mind and opinions on much of this and at
the end of the day it's still
a very
new
vaccine that we don't know the long-term
effects on and more and more you know
i'm reading information from
the u.s army that keeps data there's
they're seeing now in vaccinated people
there was a couple whistleblowers came
forward
an increased rate in cancers and in
other afflictions now it's too early to
tell you know exactly what there but
i would never fault and i don't think i
should we should discriminate against
somebody who is concerned about their
health
and about any long-term effect they may
have from
the vaccination and or fertility
potential fertility issues
and for all those reasons i believe that
this should be an individual choice
uh
universities and colleges are certainly
free to
to use other means to
enforce social distancing if they
believe that makes a difference when it
comes to mass
we've seen that
again at the retail establishment
everybody's wearing a mask
all the time in there and again it it it
spreads so
some of these things that maybe make us
feel good and again i i don't let me
back up and say it's an individual
choice and i respect any choice somebody
makes but again i believe at the end of
the day it should be the individual's
choice
not
um
a college or university not the state
government i believe it should be up to
the individual and we could particularly
with what we know now i think we can do
that in a way that does not
really change
the the final outcome
many states
have elected to go different ways during
the pandemic at the end of the day if
you look at data it it comes down to
pretty much we're all in kind of in the
same spot
between the beginning and now
some places have suffered more
economically
and there's been plenty of um increase
of
particularly in the student population
of people that are suffering from
depression and suicide rates have gone
up so that's a that's a is a byproduct
of all of this
so anyway to kind of wrap up my
my um testimony here
um particularly where this targets
higher education institutions that take
state money i believe
if they're taking state money they
should be very careful that they don't
create classes and discriminate against
people that elect not to take the
vaccine
i thank you for listening today i hope
you consider not to pass motion on house
bill 12
33 this concludes my
testimony and i would be glad to answer
any questions that you may have thank
you very much representative are there
questions from the committee
representative
tanner thank you mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
i was wondering if you could succinctly
in in a sentence or two just say what
your intent
as succinctly as i can the intent um
which i did speak to is to ensure that
students
every student
irregardless of their vaccine status
has the right to attend a state funded
high institution
and
but it's that simple
thank you
representative woodcock
good morning chairman ladd thank you
uh representative thank you for taking
my question i just want to get clarity
on a statement i thought i heard you say
uh i thought i heard you say a moment
ago that
uh the mass and the vaccinations
this bill um
is um
has been part and parcel basically of
increasing the suicide rate
and and you were talking
after army stats uh
and everything i've read about the
increased suicide rates
has not been a reflection of masking or
vaccinations but rather the isolation
and loneliness of remote learning
so i i was wondering how you where you
get your information that's in mass and
or vaccinations uh increase suicide
rates
uh thank you representative for the
question and what i was referring to is
it was a general statement that through
the pandemic um this has been an issue
and
it it
there's a number of triggers i mean
everything from people losing their
businesses to people that you know
you know
have their choices denied somebody that
wants to go to a new hampshire
university that can't now because they
feel very strongly
that they
you know
they don't want to take what they feel
is the risk
to what long-term effects may be out
there you know we we take a look i'm i'm
not one who watches tv but
anytime you see a
pharmaceutical company advertising
various um
cures that they have
they go on and on about all the side
effects that they have that's that's
without exception but you don't hear
about any side effects with this and
and i hope and pray that there won't be
any significant ones but
where it's such a new
uh
vaccine
i respect and understand why some people
might not want to partake
thank you
go ahead
thank you so a follow-up then it's it's
your general statement
of of the suicide rate based on max or
that had nothing to do with statistical
facts or metrics
as he said
thanks for the follow-up again i'm not
suggesting that it's necessarily because
of
wearing a vaccine
wearing a mask or not or whether they've
taken the
vaccination or not cumulatively
cumulatively
with what we've done and this is part of
what we've done adds to that
depression thank you thank you
thank you very much further questions
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thank you next person we like to call
forward is
tim cronin tom tom cronin from
uh good morning mr chairman members of
the committee tom cronin director of
government relations for the university
system of new hampshire thank you for
having us here this morning uh
we are opposed to uh house bill 1233
maybe i'll just start quickly with a
clarification uh no institution at the
university system of new hampshire
requires the covet 19 vaccination for
enrollment uh i think the community
college system would say the same but
i'll let ms reed speak to that in a
moment
uh we focused our testimony on largely
on the mask portion of the legislation
uh as that is something that is
currently in our toolbox to try and
prevent the spread of coven 19 on our
campuses
throughout the pandemic we've adjusted
our campus guidance around masking
gathering distancing and other guidance
really based on on three i think
important pieces one public health
guidance from the state and from the cdc
community transmission rates that we
track and report on regularly and then
the unique characteristics of a busy
residential
group of college campuses
the flexibility to adapt based on those
conditions have largely helped us to
keep our case counts on our campuses
well below our regional averages and i
think most importantly to us and really
to our students and their families is
they've helped us to keep our campuses
open
we think it's important that we retain
our flexibility to continue to adjust
these requirements based on local
conditions and based on ever evolving
guidance that is how we sort of make our
decisions around what we ask our
students our faculty and our staff to do
to try and keep each other and our
communities and our host communities for
that matter safe as we're continuing to
understand this virus and try and all
get through it together
um i think that more or less summarizes
what i'd like to share but of course i'd
be happy to take questions from all of
you thank you very much questions
i was just wondering if you were aware
how some of your
students felt i know a number of them
came to me
their admittance fees and had been told
prior to that that no masks and then by
the next day suddenly there were masks
and
uh quite a few of your students came and
said you've got to do something they
lied
so i i think broadly and i did check
this prior to this conversation today to
make sure i was right broadly our
students are supportive of the
requirements they appreciate that it is
a community requirement that folks are
wearing mass and trying to slow the
spread um i i appreciate those students
who if you recall where we were in in
terms of transmission and this virus
back when students were paying initial
deposits to start last fall right we
were in the summer of 2021 when
community spread was significantly lower
i don't know if we had started even
hearing of delta yet we certainly hadn't
heard of omicron yet we were in a very
different place and that i think is the
the crux of our testimony is the ongoing
flexibility to continue to evolve
how we
react in an attempt to
to to slow this virus on our residential
campuses
thank you representative moffitt thank
you mr thank you mr cronin for being
here what are the potential consequences
to a student who
defies a mask requirement thanks
representative um we
for both students and employees have
different disciplinary processes for any
violations of agreed-upon rules and
requirements right so students
follow what is called the student rules
rights and responsibilities
if there are violations of that they
can go through a conduct process that
attempts to understand exactly what
again checked this before uh kind of
anticipating that question we have had
no students have any serious
disciplinary issues related to masking
thank you
i have one question then represent
cordell are there any exceptions to
wearing masks like during athletic
events etc
yes is the short answer uh i would need
to
i'd want to drill down exactly on on
where you were
asking but right if you watch our
athletic events you don't see students
wearing masks while they're playing
does that also apply to those who are
observing no so in for example the
whittemore center
you are required to wear masks thank you
representative cordelli
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
cronin
i've had several conversations with a
lady i know whose daughter attends unh
but has been
forced out of the nursing program
because of vaccination requirements
in working
and
naturally is very upset about that
what
maybe is the policy or um
what happens with a nursing student
who is unvaccinated
thank you representative um so i'll say
a couple things i do know there was at
least another piece of legislation i
forget if it was in hhs or labor that
specifically tried to speak to that
clinical piece
broadly for us as universities we
partner with clinical sites in an effort
to ensure that our students in nursing
and other health professions have the
opportunity to gain the real world
experience they need to pass their
license exams and become employed in the
state
in so doing we follow the rules that
those clinical sites set for their
employees so in that case i am going to
assume that
the site that the student was placed at
had a vaccination requirement for their
employees as such our student in order
to be placed there has to follow those
same rules
follow-up
yes thank you um
do you have exemptions such as medical
exemptions for that requirement or um if
they have had covet and have natural
antibodies um
which i think is part of the
so again that is not a policy that we
have it is a policy that the clinical
site has so i would ask the clinical
site do you have an exemption uh for
medical for
uh
pre-existing
exposure
one last one last
do you have
clinical facilities that do not have
vaccination requirements or
allow for medical exemptions
i would need to double check um again i
think that's a little bit of a better
question for uh
but what i will say is we are challenged
with the number of clinical sites that
are available to our students this is
this is a long-running challenge in
terms of our ability to put more health
care professionals into
a bottleneck in terms of where they can
uh go and get this this required
clinical experience um so the number of
sites are limited the number of
placements are limited so i can't speak
to exactly uh what the various
requirements for all of them you
mentioned nursing but there are similar
rules in other allied health professions
uh where the rules may be different so i
can't speak exactly i'm happy to do a
quick follow-up and see what i can get
back to you on that but obviously
as i think you know those requirements
are are becoming more and more uh
broad-based
in healthcare
uh i have one question representative
go ahead first
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you mr cronin for taking my question
representative trojan
made reference to college students
leaving new hampshire as a result of
vaccine or mask requirements
do you at the university have any sense
of admission numbers or transfer numbers
and how
they would relate to the vaccine or the
masks
we don't um so
two pieces of that question again we do
not have a vaccination requirement so
there can be no to my knowledge a reason
why somebody would leave because of
vaccine requirement we can say however
that if you look at our peers around the
country and in new england there are a
number of schools that do have
vaccination requirements and we did hear
early on from parents that they are
concerned about sending their children
to a school that doesn't have a
stronger push towards a vaccine um so
it's unclear if we didn't enroll
students who chose instead to go
somewhere else but again we do not have
a vaccine requirement so i can't see why
students would leave because of a
vaccine requirement uh and then again
broadly uh understanding there are cases
of individuals who
would rather not be wearing a mask i
think we'd all rather not be wearing a
mask we'd all rather not have a
contagious airborne virus that we're
dealing with also
broadly i think uh
we have very good compliance amongst our
students on on masking requirements
and i'll just ask mine very quickly and
i think you can give me a quick answer
in that
the vaccines that students have we i've
heard the percentages for keen psu unh
they're quite high
at least you know as in percentage-wise
several months ago do you have any of
that information available now of what
you have as students that have been
vaccinated yeah we are in the high 80
percent among students it's actually
probably higher if you take everybody
together
yes so we have a very highly vaccinated
population of students employees and
faculty voluntarily does that include
the those campuses which were in the
lower percentage like like keen at that
time yes everybody has continued to
trend upwards and i'm happy to get exact
numbers for each of the campuses and get
those over to you thank you
not seeing any other questions thank you
very much thank you all
the next
person on
good morning my name is sally stoddy i
live in dover new hampshire
i'm commenting as a
self-interested citizen on this
because i think
what we're seeing are more and more
government
type regulations
on everything in life related to
anything they can
uh so i am in support of this bill
and i'm very interested
to see the science and i worked in
medical research for 40 years
in infectious disease transplant other
disease areas i'm interested to see the
data that show
an example used by one infectious
disease person who i'm familiar with
said using a mask
to eliminate passage of a virus is like
using a chain-link fence to keep the
mosquitoes out
the poor size
in a mask even the n95s which are coming
from china by the way most of them
they're not stopping passage of a virus
and certainly not
all the rest of the masks that everyone
is wearing even if you're double masked
so
slowing the spread is
an issue that people keep using the
words of
but yet they're not showing the science
that would that would
if we have 80 or more of
college kids
vaccinated now uh
you know we were told initially that
vaccination stops the spread
and the infection i mean the the true
definition of vaccination is preventing
infection and preventing transmission
and interestingly now the cdc has tried
to change the definition of vaccination
to
prevent
um
serious infection something to that
effect they're changing the definition
of what vaccine actually means so
there's a clear
there's a clear government
desire to
change
how we think about things like this
and for us to adopt whatever they say
um
if we're look we're talking about safety
the adverse event reporting with these
vaccines
and
um the whole process is so under
reported
it's it's seriously dangerous and for
these young people
these young adults they are in the
highest bracket of to see the adverse
events
so to see that we're in the high 80
percent in the vaccinations of all the
unh type campuses
is quite concerning and i wonder who is
pursuing
reporting of adverse events with those
students
but back to the masks
they really don't do anything that has
been clearly documented
relative to viral
transmission
that's the point i think is most
important
thank you
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee yes representative
waltz
thank you very much um
so you have made a lot of assertions
here and you have not given us any of
the scientific information based on this
and i'm wondering if you have any
studies to support your assertions that
masks are not helpful that adverse
events are high particularly among young
people
and i just you know it's you can say
anything you want
we get an enormous amount of email and
information every day that includes a
lot of scientific studies that actually
contradict what you're saying and i'm
wondering if you have the scientific
studies on the other side to prove what
you're saying i can certainly uh forward
them to people um i certainly didn't
come
you know ready to
share them with anybody here today but i
can certainly send them to whomever
would be the point person
follow-up go ahead
um
you also
reference that the cdc is changing some
of its recommendations and observations
along the way
would you agree that as more scientific
information becomes available it's
appropriate to update your
recommendations and information based on
the additional information that's coming
out as this pandemic progresses
well i'm not saying that recommendations
cannot be fluid based on how
how the
pandemic has gone but when you redefine
the word vaccine and vaccination that
has been in place for 75 years just to
fit
a current situation
that's not scientific
so if there's a point person that i can
forward the links to i will be most
happy to do so yes you can uh on the web
you you we have a site where you can
email directly to all committee members
or to any individual on the committee
and we also have a committee researcher
that we can get after this hearing we
can give you the data email address as
well i would i would appreciate that
because i can supply those thank you so
much
okay the next individual is shannon reed
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is shannon reed i
am director of government affairs for
the community college system of new
hampshire
i'm here this morning to speak in
opposition to house bill 1233.
this bill would remove the ability of
our institutions to manage campus
environments in ways that support
on-site learning
while the community college system does
not have a covid 19 vaccination
requirement we do consider the ability
to require masks in certain
circumstances to be an important tool to
keep our campuses open for in-person
learning
we are therefore opposed to a statutory
prohibition on our college's ability to
require masks or facial coverings
community colleges are known for
hands-on learning
ranging from programs like nursing
respiratory therapy
radiation therapy dental assisting
to firefighting welding
diesel technology hvac and many more
focused on-site in-person classroom and
lab work is critical and indispensable
to these and many other programs that we
offer
in march of 2020 our colleges shifted
almost entirely to remote learning as
did most of the colleges and
universities in the country
in the summer of 2020 we began bringing
students back to on-site instruction
beginning with our lab courses
in bringing students back we implemented
several strategies to mitigate the
potential spread of covid these included
reconfiguring classrooms and lab spaces
installing plexiglass dividers adjusting
scheduling improving ventilation
reducing class sizes and in certain
circumstances requiring masks
we have adjusted our approach as local
circumstances have evolved
following community transmission rates
and being responsive to other specific
situations on our campuses i'd like you
all to picture a nursing lab
you have
a room that's set up like a hospital
wing might be with beds you have
students working together with an
instructor clustered around a mannequin
which is a technologically enabled kind
of model of a human body that can be
you can implement simulations for
certain conditions that the students are
then are then obligated to kind of
figure out and solve together
this is not a situation where you can
really socially distance from one
another or from your instructor
sure there are there are classrooms
where we might be able to
like a room like this it's a very large
room we are all spaced out
so to speak um
that's it's possible in a room like this
in some circumstances but in a lot of
our hands-on learning environments
that's simply not possible or or
feasible or realistic or effective from
a learning perspective
the use of masks in certain conditions
such as i just described
when people are likely to be in close
proximity for sustained periods of time
continues to be the recommendation of
public health authorities
and it's a tool that we can employ to
keep our colleges open to keep educating
new hampshire students and keep
graduating granite staters who will
become part of our workforce
i'd like to mention that we train
students for the professions that are in
high demand and this is even more
important now given the present labor
market dynamics
unprecedented numbers of people are
opting out of the workforce whether
they're displaced stopping out while
home lives and domestic economies are
disrupted or choosing to be part of the
great resignation
our students are enrolled in community
college programs because they want to
work
they want to complete their their
training and take their place as nurses
medical assistants electrical line
workers cdl drivers firefighters and
paramedics chefs pipe welders child care
teachers and more and more
we can only help them do that if we have
the tools to keep their learning
environments open and accessible to them
and to the faculty whose role is
critical to preparing the next wave of
our state's workforce
we strongly believe that requiring masks
in certain circumstances has been a key
element in our ability to do that
just last month we graduated a class of
40 new lpns from river valley community
college
these students were able to complete
their program of study without
significant disruption and we believe
the fact that they were masked while
working together in classrooms and labs
as they will in the workplace was an
important part of our ability to to help
them complete the program
these 40 lpns and all the newer cohorts
of students who are going through the
program now are desperately needed in
today's assisted living facilities
hospitals and other environments
as you're no doubt hearing from your
constituents in your districts across
the state
we do not believe that masking is too
high a burden to protect the education
of students like these new nurses
when i was preparing testimony i reached
out to our college leadership to ask if
they had heard a lot of complaints from
students about the masking requirement
and the answer was was
very resoundingly no in fact they had
more complaints before
we were requiring masks in these indoor
circumstances
because people were concerned about
their safety they were concerned about
their ability to continue to come to
campus for that on-site instruction i
have a few letters that i'll submit from
students at our colleges
i'd like to just read a couple excerpts
for you
one is from a respiratory care student
at river valley community college
he says the high quality of the programs
in new hampshire's community college
network will not only equip me with the
skill set needed to care for the state's
sickest patients but afford me the
financial stability to support my family
it's of the highest importance to me
that it's higher education system
promotes a safe learning environment and
keeps students attending in-person
classes
he also notes a high percentage of
healthcare workers who have experienced
burnout and he says if i am to
successfully join the ranks to support
new hampshire's healthcare workforce
it's important that policies protect
both the professional and the patient
setting starting not in the icu but in
the classroom
a letter from a nursing student at nhgi
she says she's lived in the lakes region
her whole life and hopes to work locally
once she graduates providing nursing
care to fellow new hampshire residents
and she says wearing masks is what makes
me feel safe going to my classes labs
and clinical assignments it is also a
standard practice in healthcare and has
helped to protect the patients i work
with each week in clinical
she said it's essential that we're able
to participate in on-site hands-on
learning and wearing masks is one way to
keep students from becoming sick missing
classes
and missing those clinical experiences
a final letter i have is from the
student government association at great
bay community college saying this bill
would disrupt the precautionary systems
we have in place to ensure the safety of
our students from the exposure to the
coveted illness we know that layered
measures such as immunizations masks
sufficient ventilation and other
regulations may help save lives and
guarantee that our students and
instructors can remain in in-person
educational environments
so i hope you'll listen to the voices of
our students
in considering
the wisdom of this bill and that
concludes my testimony i'm happy to take
questions
thank you representative litchfield
thank you for taking my question and
thank you for your testimony
i just want to clarify would this bill
prohibit any student from wearing a mask
if they deemed necessary no this bill
would prohibit the colleges from
requiring that as a community we are in
certain
spaces and circumstances all wearing
masks
further questions
thank you and thank you for having me
here
um over the course of the last four
weeks
i haven't been before this committee
i've been to a number of other house
bills
in regards to i like to call them
freedom
mandates mass
all of all of this it's been two years
and it's time to end it all
and there seems to be a common theme
people on our side um
we're just individuals again i'm just at
groves from hooksett new hampshire i do
have a daughter at keene state college
which i'll get to that in a second
um but at other hearings it's it's just
individuals coming here to fight for our
freedoms and the other side
um seems to be you know paid lobbyists
lawyers hospital administrators and it
seems to be all about the money they're
they're worried that you know all these
bills if we pass them we're gonna lose
all this federal funding and
we we've got to get beyond that because
it's not going to happen they're not
going to stop our medicaid money if we
if we pass these bills it's not going to
happen
states break federal laws all the time
and i'll just say sanctuary cities they
still get their money
um
getting back to
this bill and all of these bills i'm
here to save the children we have
tortured and i'm going to use that word
torture because i've seen it
our kids for two years
imagine a three-year-old who's now five
who's been stuck in a mask
what's going through that kid's head
i've watched my daughter graduated
manchester central i think last year i
don't know if i even got the diploma yet
she spent half her junior year in her
senior year on her bed on a computer
and she is now at keene state college
she got in she's doing great her first
semester was a 3.37
she's not vaccinated she went to that
school with a friend of hers from
hooksett who was not vaccinated 30 days
into their first semester her roommate
she came home crying i got covered blah
blah blah blah blah okay well you will
deal with it and correct me if i'm wrong
this is directly to you guys
um
she was taken for 10 days put in
isolation with all the other coveted
kids
meanwhile my daughter who's now living
alone
couldn't because she wasn't vaccinated
she had to go to another dorm of
isolation for 10 days or she had the
option of going home
so she called me crying all alone in a
room with in a dorm with no other people
i guess there was one ra there
and she just felt again 18 years old
freshman at college
isolated alone and just trying to just
trying to go to school
um
after three days she called me because i
said why don't you just come home she
chose not to
acclimated to it said hey i got my own
bathroom i get to eat alone i can study
i got my own tv anyway the point of the
story is
that she went back to her second
semester and about a week into her
second semester she was visited by a
girl named kathy who said she was an
advocate for the for the school
and she was a senior and she was asked
well how'd your first semester go great
blah blah blah blah blah and then
towards the end i got into the you know
the cover discussion and she asked my
daughter why she wasn't vaccinated and
she said well that's my choice my father
doesn't want me to be vaccinated i don't
want to be vaccinated and that's that
and she said well you might as well
and again correct me if
this doesn't sound
like something an advocate would do
said why don't you just you might as
well get vaccinated because by the time
you graduate you're going to have to be
vaccinated anyway so
i'm not sure why that was said to her
i'm not sure who this cathy girl was
but
these kids have enough to do just
getting their studies done and not
having to worry about being vaccinated
or wearing a mask and
you mentioned about the evidence of
whether the masks work or not there's
been doctors at all of these other
hearings i i've got the notes and i can
find these the doctor yesterday in one
of the meetings he phenomenal i forget
his name but he went through details
about
the cloth masks the n95s and and micron
sizes and everything and
if you do the research the cloth masks
really are
fairly useless now so you know
we got to move on i mean we're the
united states of america there's
countries like well denmark let me get
this straight yesterday
no longer considers covet 19 socially
uh critical disease they're moving on
they're opening up their country and now
i don't want to get this is not a
bill about house bill 1022 iver mechton
but if you want new hampshire to get
ahead of the game and out of this
coveted mess
ivormectin works i took it for five days
starting new year's day
it was with a number of other drugs with
vitamins and zinc
it's an amazing drug please do your
research on that other countries are
getting out of covet india
japan
it works it's been fda approved since
1987 they just need to repurpose it
thank you thank you very much are there
any questions representative are you
willing to take a question
representative moffatt thank you mr and
thank you for coming in and
making the effort
uh you mentioned that kathy the advocate
at keene state uh
asked your daughter about a vaccination
status how did this
advocate as you put it how did she know
your daughter's vaccination status
that's what i'd like to know but they
all know it
the kids all know it too as a matter of
fact
the kids are making a mockery of this
okay
they have five or more kids in their
dorm it's a spreader party if they have
ten or more it's a super spreader then
they have the ultra super spreaders
these guys are having fun with this at
our expense i mean
the kids know that this
the vaccine
well it doesn't work let's face it it
does not work
and i'm driving here this morning
listening to an advertisement for pfizer
now has a double shot dose for six month
old babies
this is out of control
but no i don't know how kathy the
advocate i'm i'm actually looking into
this mike
you know how kids are dad stay away stay
away don't get involved don't you know
but i'm concerned that an advocate would
thank you thank you very much are there
further questions
not seeing any thank you very much
good morning my name is carla smith i'm
a registered nurse i'm here representing
the new hampshire nurses association and
we are in opposition of this bill
i would also like to share with you my
personal perspective today i am a
professor of nursing in new hampshire
i work at a private university and quite
in contrast
we have very strict
restrictions on our campus
we do require masking
we require vaccination unless you have
an exemption in place
we require weekly testing
the community system and unh system here
in new hampshire i they just want
flexibility they're not asking to go to
this strict rigid
form that i live every day
i had my pcr test done on on monday so i
could be cleared to be safe to be in
campus and therefore i'm safe to be here
with you today
doesn't bother me
i have 129 nursing students in my
program right now
we haven't lost a single one with the
most stringent restrictions there could
possibly be
i have two students that do have
exemptions for vaccines
we have worked with them to find them
clinical sites and opportunities
that still fit within the course
objectives because that's very important
you can't just send a nurse a student
anywhere to complete these clinical
hours it has to meet their course and
their learning objectives
but we've been able to find those
exceptions for them
having a mask mandate or having a
vaccine policy has not restricted their
learning in any way
and like i said we haven't lost any
students if anything our program has
only grown
because they truly want to be part of
this workforce solution this nursing
with all of these restrictions i have to
tell you i feel the safest
on campus than i do anywhere else i feel
safer going to work
than i do going to the grocery store
going to the gas station
it's not a burden it's only a help
in contrast to some of the comments that
have been made
by previous speakers today
yes these systems are funded by public
tax dollars but you know what what else
do we fund with public tax dollars we
fund our military systems we fund our
law enforcement officers
body armor
bulletproof vests those are all tools
that prevent
or help to prevent
a devastating injury
would we defund that
may not stop them
from becoming hurt
but you know what it's going to prevent
them from having that mortality and
that's what masks do that's what
vaccines do no one's saying that they
can 100 stop the spread of covet
but they certainly minimize that risk
i think that's something that's
important to to consider if you can
minimize risk why are we taking that
i think that's very important to know
lastly i want to share some
financial perspective that i think is
worth considering i got my research from
becker's hospital review it's considered
they broke down the cost of a coveted
hospitalization case by each state
this research was published in december
in the state of new hampshire a complex
coveted hospitalization
that means the person's admitted to the
hospital has received icu treatment and
is intubated
256 thousand dollars
the average cost for a non-complex case
meaning they were admitted to the
hospital
maybe on a general floor needed some
respiratory support some oxygen but did
not require icu or do not require
intubation
sixty two thousand dollars
sixty two thousand dollars that's more
than the average teacher makes in new
hampshire
two hundred fifty six thousand dollars i
could go buy a house
if we can minimize
these costs and that's what vaccinations
do that's what masks do they decrease
the risk
as for these super spreader parties
would you have your children play
russian roulette
just because they can because they can
get together it's really a gamble
i think it's very important that we
allow these universities to have the
flexibility
to institute these mask policies or a
vaccination policy if they feel it's fit
to safeguard their community
and have the best health outcomes thank
you thank you are there questions
not seeing any hands thank you
i'm just curious as to how much um
you've seen of covet on your campus
we have seen it but i have to say it's
been very little the last time i looked
up our positivity rate was less than
three percent thank you you're welcome
further questions
not seeing any thank you very much
kathleens and tavi dover new hampshire
and i'm speaking in support of this bill
our students when they go away to
college
are able to drive handle their finances
do research of all types
so they are asked to make adult
decisions
day in and day out
whether or not to wear a face mask
is an adult decision that certainly this
age group
should be able to do based upon the
research that is available at that point
in time
also based upon
what i have read
this age group is the most healthy age
group of all
and the least likely to have bad effects
from contracting covet
what we do then is we will draw their
blood and use it to create
the antibody plasma
that we give to people who are older or
have very adverse effects to help get
them
over the hump of their illness
the only according to what i have read
the only face mask that actually works
for the teeny tiny particles that are
the virus it's an n95 that is properly
fitted
i don't know if anyone in this room has
an n95 mask on but i do it is my
understanding that they are difficult to
come across and from what i've read
cloth masks really do not do a lot of
good that they may help you for a few
minutes if somebody is close by but
in between the fibers those little tiny
particles of
illness will go right through
the fabric
the cdc
yes they do get more and more
information
but they are also not all that good in
getting the information out in an
understandable way to the public and
what has happened is a loss of trust in
what they are putting out there
my concern
are students who are on the autistic
spectrum
students who are deaf students who have
504 or iep plans who are in the
university
who may need to read lips or who may not
be able to have a face covering on but
yet we are requiring it so what are we
doing i have not heard accommodations
that are being made for this type of
student who would like to attend the
vaccines should be they are
a choice that people should make
regarding their own health
from what i've read the vaccines do not
work against the omicron variant which
is a far weaker variant than previous
strains
and that it is not as deadly or as
lethal for many people and i have
friends right now who have this who have
been triple vaccinated who do wear masks
but they still i have two friends that i
get emails from this morning who have
this
so it's telling me that you're asking
people or requiring people to put a
vaccine in their body that they don't
know what the long-term effects are and
yet it is not working universally like
it was put out to do originally
so we have a lot of unknown effects for
the vaccine but i'm just wondering why
the government is saying we have to wait
55 years to read the data from moderna
pfizer and johnson and johnson
why is that being withheld from the
public
if there are no ill effects to this
so
i am hoping that you will strongly
consider giving back
freedom to our young adults so that they
will further learn their rights and
responsibilities in the great state of
new hampshire
thank you
are there any questions from the
committee
heath
hello thank you for having me my name is
heath howard i'm a resident of stratford
a lifelong resident of new hampshire i
am currently a junior at the university
of new hampshire
i am quite appalled by the bill that has
been proposed
before us and i feel strongly that it
undermines the health and safety
initiatives that the university system
has put in place to protect our students
i know personally that some of the
infrastructure at the university of new
hampshire
allows for more cramped classrooms than
would be preferred
allowing for
the prevention of uh social distancing
meaning that masks are really the front
line of protection among students
uh personally i know some uh
some of my friends who have hearing
disabilities who are all for the mask
mandate that is currently in place
they do not struggle they have hearing
aids and if necessary
there are sas opportunities for students
i did want to address one thing one of
the questions from one of the
representatives about
how students have been leaving the state
i know that before covet even hit around
60 percent of our high school graduates
were leaving the state to attend
out-of-state universities for those who
were going on to pursue higher education
and that's mostly due to the highest
in-state tuition in the nation that we
currently have
alongside that
it's also important that we actually
have
protection among students
and i feel strongly that you should vote
against this bill thank you
thank you very much are there questions
not seeing any thank you very much for
coming up today
thank you
good morning everybody good morning
um
my name is jenny wilson and i am a
resident of barrington new hampshire
and i am here to speak in support of
this bill
and i'm going to make this very short
and sweet
the reason i i decided to speak is
because i want to share with you my own
personal experience
this is not anecdotal i didn't hear this
from my neighbor or anybody else
but my husband
has had the two shots
and uh just recently he got a phone call
saying from his musical group one of
them came down with covet and he said
you need to test yourself
when my husband was having the symptoms
and he tested himself and he tested
positive
and uh
he looked at me and he said
you better test yourself because i have
not been vaccinated
and i have not received any of the
vaccinations
so i said okay he went to the store and
got four of the
rapid tests
he tested himself twice and both times
he was positive
i tested and i was negative
this is my own personal experience
we don't wear masks in the house we live
together we're married to each other we
don't keep six feet of distance
and i hear all this information about
being this virus being so deadly
and so contagious that you have to stay
away you have to wear a mask you have to
wear two masks
and
this is just my personal experience and
i want to tell you i'm not a spring
chicken i am just one year away from
being 70.
so
you know i'm not like 25 years old that
can you know leap tall buildings in a
single bound so
um just
sharing this information with you and
you can do with it what um you like but
i think that masks don't do anything and
vaccinations are
pretty risky in my opinion that's why i
haven't gotten mine
thank you for hearing me
thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee
70 is not a spring chicken
very much a spring chicken
wait till you get about six or seven on
top of that
then it changes thank you thanks for
coming
um we have another card here from we
have two more cards
uh we have a card from
sean locke who is from the
new hampshire department of justice is
it doj
thank you chairman ladd uh good morning
cheerlead and members of the education
committee my name is sean locke
i'm an assistant attorney general i
direct the attorney general's civil
rights unit i'm here on behalf of the
attorney general to provide
informational testimony so to be clear
the ag does not take a position on the
underlying policy
but asks particularly if the committee
is considering an ought to pass
recommendation that the committee bear
in mind
the need for schools of all types to
protect and accommodate the needs of
students with disabilities
as the committee may be aware states
including iowa florida texas virgin and
recently virginia have passed laws or
issued
orders prohibiting mass requirements or
leaving mask wearing to the sole
discretion of either students or the
parents of students
these laws have been challenged by
parents disability rights advocates and
the federal government
as recently as last week the 8th circuit
court of appeals
found that schools need to consider
whether or not
other students their need their
expectation to wear masks to protect and
accommodate their peers with
disabilities
yes comes because the legislation has
currently drafted may cause confusion
for schools in determining how to follow
this law while also protecting students
with disabilities as they need to under
other state law the americans with
disabilities act and the rehabilitation
act
and
happy to take questions it's also a
theme you'll probably hear multiple
times for me over the coming weeks as
there are other mass legislation before
the committee thank you uh
representative luna
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much attorney lock for um uh for
joining us this morning
um do um would a uh would a compromised
immune system be considered a disability
it could be unders and so one thing i
will say about the accommodation process
it's a fact intensive process so
i'll do my best to kind of answer
hypotheticals but i can't necessarily
speak in absolutes but yes there are
circumstances where that could be a
disability
thank you on a follow-up yes would um
would all
um state regulations or state laws be an
infringement on civil rights and if you
could give us an example of um maybe one
that is
um
sorry uh
not necessarily so
in general the way particularly the
americans with disabilities act but also
state law i mean the accommodation
process would be
the ability to in you know so a person
with a disability say i need an
exemption or i need an adjustment to a
particular policy practice uh as a
result of my disability and so then
depending on the circumstances there
could be an engagement with whoever has
imposed the requirement whether it's an
employer whether it's a school
to determine what an appropriate
accommodation may be under the
circumstances and so certainly you know
under this law that could be something
that happens the concern is more the
confusion that it could create where you
have a law that says you can't require
masks but then you have laws that say
well you need to accommodate students
with disabilities and and kind of giving
making sure that it's clear that you
know both things can occur at the same
time
up one follow up on this and and are you
aware if um if those um accommodations
as you've uh discussed here are in fact
not being um um
uh integrated in with the um
with the requirements that the
university system and the community
college system are um are have in place
today i certainly haven't received
complaints with respect to the
university system or the community
college system with respect for in our
office and i would have to kind of defer
to other agencies about whether or not
they've received similar complaints but
where
they're expecting mass i haven't
received complaints that masks are
infringing on anybody's rights as people
with disabilities
representative porter
thank you mr chair this is a question
that's been percolating in my mind as
i've been listening
so right now we're hearing a lot about
the coveted vaccine and
masks and that maybe not being effective
for
for transmission of covert but if in the
illness would have happened where we
knew
for sure that the vaccine would prevent
it and we knew for sure
that wearing a mask would prevent
transmission would having this
language in place
prevent the universities and and
colleges
from implementing or requiring those
so my
you follow where i'm going yes i'm
looking
right now
we're here but 10 years from now
what's going to happen if this is in
place right and so my read of the
legislation would be
at least with respect to the vaccine
requirement is explicitly to the covet
19 vaccine so if there's a future
disease or a vaccine work this law may
not apply but i'm pretty i'm fairly
certain if i
please correct me if i'm wrong that it
says
covet related vaccines but for mass
requirements that's that seems absolute
it doesn't it's not just limited to
preventing transmission of covet so it
could be a concern that arises in
if there was a future disease
thank you i have a question
i could take you to john farmela maybe
but uh i'll i'll deal with you uh
the issue of
eliminating state funds
if mass are required we know that in
certain situations we've heard that word
circumstances that they're required
is there potential for suits to come
back against the state
for
loss of scholarship money that's paid
revenues which go to either the
community college system or the
university system in new hampshire or
other like situations where
we are now discriminating against a
person that maybe doesn't have the
wherewithal to
attend
so let me make sure i understand your
correct question correctly before i
answer so you're you're kind of
describing a situation where state funds
are used to pay a scholarship to a
particular student and they're choosing
to go to the university that was just
one example of possibly how state monies
could be used right um so i'm i'm and
with the this
if a a
system or institution within the other
system
decide we are going to go have continue
this mandate whereas and if this bill
pat were to pass would we then have you
know
the that type of condition occur whether
it be you know litigation brought
against the state
i don't because i mean the issue would
have to one i highly doubt the
university system or the community
college system would would
refuse all the state funding that they
receive if the law were to pass but i
won't speak for them but they
but if you had a student so they want to
use their scholarship at a university at
a state university that's requiring a
mass requirement with this lawn effect
so the
law itself would prohibit
i apologize i'm thinking aloud as i'm
saying this
the law would prohibit
state funds from going to the university
and so the question would be basically
would that scholarship have i guess it's
two parts one would that scholarship
have to be rescinded as a result of that
choice and two
what remedy the student would have if
that scholarship would rescinded that's
correct um
i'm not sure i have i'd have to really
think more about that particular
question to answer it correctly or to
give you kind of a more complete answer
um
and just because the issue is kind of
the student's choice and where they want
to use that scholarship
you know that that they may be able to
use it in a different state if the
program allows them to use in a
different state or if it's exclusive to
new hampshire it really comes down to
that students choices and kind of like
this indirect funding a use of state
funds into the university system i'm
talking about the money which goes for
in our operational budget goes directly
to
university system new hampshire right
then the university of new hampshire
decides throughout we're going to use
some of that to offset the cost for for
a student that is coming from an
economic situation where they cannot pay
full full freight
okay so i see so you're saying
basically if the money isn't going to
the university system to pay for these
scholarships would the students have
it'd be state money flowing to the
system
and the system you know uses money in a
whole lot of different ways it's just
one example how they may use it and i'm
just looking at are there any possible
results which we could end up
in litigation as a result of following
i would assume i again i i can't
it's a possibility but i can't think of
a concrete example at the top of my head
i mean there's certainly
always the risk for litigation when when
someone is denied funding
um whether or not that is kind of
successful litigation is something i
would have to think more carefully about
before thank you very much
are there further questions
yes um
what about the issue of competing
disabilities if somebody really needed
to be able to see somebody's
facial expressions mouth etc for
understanding etc
would they be able to have their class
be maskless if it was a mask mandate
so considering that particular question
i remember you i think you had mentioned
it earlier or someone had mentioned kind
of the seeing the face they do make
masks that have kind of the clear panel
across the person's mouth so you can
continue to read lips my understanding
is certain law enforcement agencies may
use this when they're interacting with
members of the public to enable that
um but so there is an opportunity there
thank you are there any further
questions thank you very much and your
good morning
i wasn't expected to
speak today but since i heard everybody
else's testimony i feel like i have
something to say
um i'm a retired recreation therapist i
worked at
concord hospital here in the
state hospital i worked at the state
prison i've been a state worker um i'm a
wellness professional as a recreation
therapist
and um as retired i went into another
kind of field more into the fitness and
wellness and um
i worked at the wellness center in
peterborough
i'm currently at hampshire hills
i'm not wearing a mask today because
i
very early on read the research and
decided i was not going to do the
vaccine
i used a mask during when i was working
but when
the
um
you know two years ago in march when i
was working at the wellness center um
they turned us over to close the
wellness center
and we were told to
um wear masks and then now be front line
and so for five months i worked front
line
doing check-in
for temperatures i still didn't get sick
i'm a big advocate of health and
wellness and exercise and vitamins
um
and i wanted to say a little bit about
some of my experiences um i was doing a
pcr because my husband's a diplomat
we're part-time down in the bahamas and
um i had to take a pcr test to fly down
to the bahamas
and i had my mask on my n95 that i see
many people wearing today
it gives you a little bit more oxygen
and i said i would like to test
my oxygen level while i'm sitting here
at resting level because that's what
something i was doing with all my
cardiac patients and
in the wellness center and i knew the
levels of
what was somebody that was ill and
somebody that was normal and i my oxygen
level was usually about a 97 i'm an
athlete
um to 99 when i was working out
and it turned out to be 95
which was the level of my cardiac oldest
most sickest patient
and i was like whoa
um
what is happening to us in a society
wearing these masks and what is
happening to our
young children and young adults wearing
these masks
nobody's researching this and i just
wanted to tell you that this is my
experience
i also was i'm involved in rise up new
hampshire very minimally
i went to a support group
and there were about seven or eight of
us
this is before i got
covid which i did on thanksgiving
my husband's fully vaccinated because he
works for the state department
and
he got
omicron as well as my son
and we were all about at the same level
we i took ivermectin um that i had a
little bit of
we also took chaga tea and um
just to have this written down for
people to know um and wormwood which is
also a
antiviral there's lots of natural
antivirals that are out there along with
all the vitamins that i took the
increased dc zinc
quercetin
so we were all about the same level my
husband actually sicker
um
than i was and um
he has always been i've been the one
with all the respiratory problems and
the allergies and everything and he was
a lot sicker than i was um
and so i don't know what that relates to
but it could be because he was
vaccinated
um so anyways i want to go back to the
support group um
we were sitting around and there were
eight of us and um
one of them was a college nurse
she's not here today which i'm surprised
and she was so upset and it took the
whole
session to calm her down
because she told us that she had a stack
about this high
of all the college students that came in
from
their adverse reactions
their depression
from the vaccine from all the mandates
and she didn't know what to do
i told her to write it down but you know
some people
um just want to
uh
they want to keep their jobs you know so
and lastly i wanted to say i am support
of this
bill
i know that a couple weeks ago i heard
on the radio that dartmouth college was
double vaccinated and boostered and were
requiring masks and still
um 700 students got sick
so that's something to consider
maybe also consider
finding out from some of these college
nurses
um what they're seeing
um
not just from me saying this but
actually bringing in some college nurses
and and seeing what their reactions are
to
all these effects
that's all i have to say thank you very
much are there any questions from the
committee
not seeing any hands thank you very much
thanks
and without seeing any other pink cards
me
go ahead with uh hb 1332
this is a bill
accepting public universities and
colleges from requirements under medical
freedom in immunizations
so
representative shapiro
you're welcome
to be here and
we're ready for your testimony
you hit the red yeah you hit the button
there
and the red light will come on there you
go got it it's got it thank you mr
chairman and thank you committee members
for the opportunity to introduce house
bill
for the record i'm joe shapiro
representing cheshire 16 the city of
keene
this bill is a very small but important
bill it does one thing in one thing only
it takes hb 220 the medical freedom in
immunizations act passed and signed into
law last term and now enshrined in rsa
141c
colon 1 and adds one further exception
to those already listed public
institutions of higher learning
when this bill became before my
committee
last year health human services and
elderly affairs the committee had the
committee and the sponsor had the wisdom
and foresight to exempt nursing homes
and public hospitals from what was
essentially a ban on vaccine
requirements
we were told that this was because of
the congregant congregate living nature
of those institutions
we were told that people were housed in
such close proximity that requiring
vaccines by employees
might be necessary to mitigate the
spread of covet 19.
my bill proposes accepting colleges and
universities as well
dormitory living is also congregate
living
people share small bedrooms
use the same bathrooms and congregate
congregate in common living spaces and
classrooms
this bill will not require
covid 19 vaccinations
it will merely leave it as an option
should administrators
at colleges and universities with the
consultation of public health
professionals decide that it is the best
way to keep their school open with
in-person classes while protecting the
keene state college as you know is a new
hampshire public college
there is no vaccine mandate for students
faculty or staff
they have done an excellent job at
preventing overwhelming spread of covid
they have regular testing
masking and they have pioneered the use
of wastewater testing to gauge increases
in spread to to inform their policies
they have a rapid response team that
does intensive and timely contract
contact tracing
as we've heard from one of the speakers
and students who are unvaccinated must
immediately quarantine if they've been
exposed
they have stayed open and students have
been able to have a somewhat normal
college experience
also in cheshire county is franklin
pierce college which does
does have a vaccine mandate
i am not a scientist nor am i a
statistician
i know there are many variables
still both colleges have a cova
dashboard and i took a look
it's just one point in time but franklin
pierce had 2.2 active cases for 1 000
students
while keene state college had 26.6
active cases per thousand students and
that was just
last week of january
once again this is a small bill that
makes a small change it mandates nothing
rather it allows school administrators
the option of using vaccine requirements
in the future should a more lethal
variant of covid19 come along or should
there be a new and different deadly
communicable illness in the next few
years
if you were an administrator
or the parent of a college student or a
college student yourself wouldn't you
and that is the end of my
testimony i hope that you will consider
this bill and um
recommend it ought to pass and i'm
willing to take questions thank you very
much are there any questions for the
representative
not seeing the hands thank you very much
representative did you fill out a pink
card
we'll need one
thank you
thank you once again my name is carla
smith i'm a registered nurse i'm here
representing the new hampshire nurses
association and we are here i'm
submitting written testimony in support
of this bill
again
agreeing with
what was just said
college systems are congregal living we
feel that they belong in the same
exemption category as our
long-term care facilities in our new
hampshire hospital system the rest of my
comments are similar to what i shared
before so i'll keep it short and sweet
for you thank you are there any
questions
not seeing any you have written
testimony there
[Music]
good morning again mr chairman uh
members of the committee tom cronin
director of government relations for the
university system uh
thank you for having us here on house
bill 1332 we are in support of this
legislation really for two key reasons
um
first as has been mentioned
the proposal recognizes the importance
of treating residential college campuses
differently on matters of public health
than other public facilities
for a little bit of scale we have
approximately 10 000 students who live
on our campuses during the academic year
and another 18 000 or so who live off
campus but in close proximity and then
come to campus
to learn socialize with our residential
students
conditions on a residential campus
include as mentioned congregate living
dining studying athletics events and
other social opportunities
they require special protocols and extra
vigilance to protect health and the
well-being of campus
second
as you all well know rsa 187a grants
broad authority to the usnh board of
trustees to manage the property and
affairs of the university system to our
mind the continued success of usnh and
our institution depends in large measure
measure on our bot having the
flexibility to address constantly
evolving health and safety conditions
as testified to in the last hearing we
do not have a vaccination mandate at
this time there's no conversation at
this time to have a vaccine mandate i
think we can all agree however that
nobody knows what is next be it kovid be
it anything else and a law that is
currently in place um through 220 last
year that
to our reading prohibits our ability
to have a mandate on students
in the event of some sort of an outbreak
on a variant we haven't seen yet is
simply
preventing the flexibility that we spoke
to in the last hearing so really for us
this bill improves the existing
flexibility we have to try and manage
the health and safety of our campus
along with all of the other health
health measures we spoke about in the
last hearing uh
yeah so i'll conclude there and be happy
to take a question thank you very much
if this law had not been in place would
you have required vaccines thank you for
the question so it's hard to
you know that's obviously hypothetical i
can say there were conversations um
throughout last year as the vaccine came
online it was out in the public um it
was clear we are a public institution um
who has a degree of uh responsibility to
understand how you all as lawmakers feel
on these issues and it was obvious to us
from the conversations uh occurring last
year that it wasn't something that the
legislature would have been supportive
of so that certainly played into our
decision so again i can't say for sure
if 220 never happened and these
conversations never happened exactly
where we would be today um but i can say
we certainly took that as a suggestion
um and we also i think had some
confidence in our our student body in
our faculty and staff that they would
come together voluntarily um to try and
take steps to to protect each other um
as a follow-up on a question from the
last conversation um we have at unh and
at plymouth i believe we're about 80
percent of our students
are vaccinated uh keen i think they've
reported about 74
and again those are voluntarily reported
vaccination numbers so we ask uh folks
to let us know one way or another it
helps us sort of gauge how things are
going on campus so they could
potentially be higher um but that's sort
of the number we have so
largely we did fall back on knowing we
could trust our community to try to come
together and do this voluntarily thank
you
representative
thank you monsieur thank you miss corn
for being here again
exchange students come to new hampshire
from a variety of other countries with
different cultures backgrounds and
medical practices
so if this were to become law and if a
vax mandate came about on on
public campuses would exchange students
be exempted depending on their
backgrounds or they would exchange
students be mandated to get shots
uh
i'm
assuming that
they would fall under the same rules as
every other student the same way they
currently do
as i think folks are aware the
university system has a series of
required vaccinations already
and exchange students have to have to do
those as well
thank you
further questions representative tanner
thank you um and thank you for taking my
question
are international students subject to
vaccination requirements by the united
states government to actually come to
the united states to participate at a
college
further further questions representative
nelson
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
are there any exemptions for uh specific
religious reasons
thank you
yes um we have a uh both religious uh
and medical exemptions for so we're
talking about our existing uh
vaccination requirements we do have
those and they are easily understood and
accessible
and again it's maybe just a follow-up
representative tanner's question
again we have required vaccinations on
campus a student coming from anywhere to
live on campus would need to either meet
those requirements or take advantage of
existing religious or medical exemptions
so i can't say for sure exactly what the
nation on a whole provides but to come
study on our campuses
were to pass or not passed how is that
going to impact
the
situation we experienced oh at the end
of last year when we had the nasa grant
nosha now that's all been reversed right
now however by mandating the vaccination
of contractors we've lost well over 100
million dollars
in in grant funding
if we have this in place for for example
we are now re if we required
vaccinations
and then you have an or didn't require
vaccinations i'll take it didn't require
the vaccination and we had something
potentially come down
with loss of grant money
is that potent potentially an issue that
you are considering or looking at
thank you for the question mr chairman
um so i think a couple points to that
first the the nasa requirement and the
federal requirement last year was
specific to covered employees uh we view
the
existing medical freedom and
immunization law 141c colon one as
applying to students so other than a
small section of students who are also
employees we don't feel as though those
were necessarily in conflict we
understand there were some folks that
disagreed with that interpretation
and there are i believe pieces of
legislation moving in other committees
that would amend 141c to perhaps more
clearly define it as including public
employment
in that case we would be concerned that
right state law and a federal mandate
would conflict um on those bills in
particular we have submitted testimony
just to clearly state that the way the
federal guidance on that mandate um came
down was very clear that it was a duly
enacted federal uh requirement and that
it superseded any conflicting state or
local regulations to the contrary so we
obviously don't want to be in a place
where we feel like we're in conflict
well that that answers my
my question i was worried about the
student that's considered the contractor
right so in though again in those cases
they were
somewhat few
but we did let students know in that
case that if they did continue to want
to be an employee of the university they
would need to comply by the same rules
as other covered contractors if however
if they chose to no longer uh
participate in whatever in a lot of
cases work study they were currently
doing then there'd be no further
consequence uh in that regard thank you
further questions represent luno thank
you very much mr chair thank you again
mr cronin um earlier this morning we
heard from one of your students um mr
howard who uh who spoke in support of
current um
uh university system practices and i was
wondering do um have you what have you
received as far as um you know a
truckload of complaints
uh against your um your current prac
your your current practice or um
for um
required vaccination
thank you so again we do not have a
current vaccine requirement on related
to covid we do have a series of
vaccinations required for other
communicable diseases and certainly we
do each year uh have a student or two
who objects um who for any some some
reason does not fit into either the
medical or religious uh
exemption and we try to work with those
students help them understand why we
believe they're important but it's
certainly not a
widespread concern about those if that
answers your question
thank you very much uh any other
questions from the committee yes
representatives
do you have i i know you said you had
medical exemptions for
vaccines which is great do you have a
medical exemption for masks for people
who do have breathing issues and their
o2 does drop dramatically so my
understanding is we do have i think a
prior speaker mentioned
either the clear face shields or other
so i think we would work i know we will
work with students who if they have a
medical reason that they uh
feel they'd be compromised by wearing a
mask for a long period of time either we
work with them to try and provide the
opportunity to continue to intend in
person but of course every
should be careful on every
the vast majority of our
opportunities for education also could
be
achieved online for students who for
whatever reason don't feel comfortable
going into a classroom um and have
some
medical uh issue we can't help them to
accommodate but i know we do try to make
sure that if they want to be in the
classroom we're going to do what we can
to ensure that can happen thank you
thank you further questions
now saying thank you very much thank you
kathleen cintavi dover new hampshire
i first want to make abundantly clear
that college campus
is not like a rest home
which was previously stated
i have worked
in a rest home
with autistic people and so forth
people in a rest home very often have
compromised immune systems have heart
ailments or other end of life ailments
that put them at much higher risk
for
diseases that we either have now or
coming down the pike in the future that
could have dire outcomes and if we look
at the difference in
the dire outcome rate for college age
students versus rest home students there
really is no comparison
college age students are young and
healthy
but one of the biggest lessons that i
believe they need to learn during their
college years is to practice their
rights and responsibilities
and to do this by doing research so if
some future illness comes down the pike
certainly
such as we have now there is a plethora
of information that becomes available
and i believe that this bill
takes away the right of individual
students to learn to
use their rights responsibilities
and to make a critical
use of critical thinking to make the
best decision for themselves
this is a hypothetical bill that in my
opinion limits the freedom of health and
wellness decisions for an age group who
really needs to learn how to do exactly
that to make critical decisions for
themselves so when i look at it and
listen to the fact that 80 of students
at unh
what's to say that
they wouldn't do something like that
with the future illness so i am not in
support of this bill because it does
limit the rights responsibilities and
freedoms of our youth who are the future
of our state and our country
any questions thank you any questions
from the committee
yes representative woodcock thank you
chairman
thank you for taking my question um
i understand your comparison between the
nursing home situation and the college
campus
would you agree however that the
college universities does have
congregate housing and therefore has an
option to provide
uh reasonable accommodations absolutely
and and
i'm sorry
okay thank you further questions
seeing you thank you very much
thank you for having me again uh so i am
here to speak in support of this bill
of course as you know
growing up i
had gotten my vaccinations to go to
elementary school and just like every
other student
and of course you know those
vaccinations have had to be updated over
the course of my life in order to be
able to attend the university system
here in new hampshire
and i don't see why a kova 19
vaccination
would be any different of course they've
just gotten fda approval they've been
proven to be safe
they've been proven to be effective
and we need to make sure that we can
protect the staff faculty and students
that go through our higher education
system
and of course having that option to
allow for the university to institute a
vaccine mandate
would allow for the highest level of
safety that we can provide for our
students faculty and staff thank you
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee yes represent luna
sure thank you very much and thank you
very much mr howard for uh for joining
us this morning um i don't really expect
you to have a a detailed answer to uh to
this question but would you expect that
in a community
such as unh
where i think you've got close to
what sixteen thousand
i believe something like that yeah yeah
plus uh plus faculty and staff
that that among this community
population that there may be people with
disabilities including compromised
immune systems and other um
other um uh conditions that might place
them at higher risk
than say um
well that may just place them at higher
risk yeah of course uh so personally uh
i
i've had two major back surgeries uh one
of which was in 2020 uh of course you
know that put me in one of the higher
risk groups
of course i'm triple vaccinated and i
got the vaccine as soon as i was able to
um i know
of several other
students who have immune
immunocompromised systems
who have also gotten the vaccine
and it does make them feel a bit safer
of course they're still worried about
the possibility of getting kovid
and
you know that's that's a worry for all
of our students
thank you very much are there further
questions from the committee not seeing
hands thank you very much
and our last pink card which we have on
thank you
i keep hearing the word safety thrown
around
but
safety isn't being defined specifically
and and scientifically
so that's just a comment that um
the people who are in in favor of these
limitations to our freedoms
are all voicing the word safety
um
i'm kind of puzzled about this bill
because
it appears to be a hypothetical because
it's saying well we don't have a vaccine
requirement for these state universities
so
why is it actually being proposed
if we don't have a vaccine requirement
then why are we
kind of preemptively wanting to exempt
uh medical freedoms from immunizations
i'm really puzzled by that
so i have to start there
also
vaccines are not vaccines all the old
vaccines are dna vaccines they were
studied and observed for
adverse events for all kinds of
connections for decades and decades and
so we don't know
that the current vaccine
in quotes is safe
and effective we know it's not effective
in transmission and infection rates
i have a daughter who had a very serious
adverse event
immediately following the johnson and
johnson vaccine
[Music]
i reported it as a serious adverse event
to the fda and to the company which
ought to be the pattern for everyone so
that the numbers of adverse events it is
closer to being accurate
i can assure you she will never receive
another rna vaccine
um
and she is of college age so if this if
this were put in place and that and the
in the university all of a sudden
decided well we are now going to
require a vaccine
this person has now had a serious
adverse event
is she going to get a medical exemption
i'm curious on the number of medical and
other exemptions
that the university system here has
actually granted
so i think that question needs to be
answered
instead of uh well we'll make some kind
of an agreement with a student who can't
wear a mask or can't have a vaccine
we'll work something out i want to know
what the numbers are that they have
actually granted so far
i am definitely not in favor of this
bill thank you
question are you aware that johnson and
johnson is not in our mna next
mrna vaccine it's not a dna vaccine well
it's a traditional vaccine it's not the
new technology
it's a vector vaccine not an rna right
but it but it is grouped with the other
vaccines and it is so recently developed
that there is no long-term safety
associated with it
so my question to you is if johnson
johnson is not an mrna vaccine why are
you saying your daughter will never
receive another one mrna because it
sounds like she never received an
rna vaccine
she she won't receive any further ones
or boosters because of the serious
adverse event she had to this
and and the type of reaction she had is
very commonly associated with pfizer and
the moderna so it's there is overlap of
further questions not seeing any hands
thank you very much and our last person
hi i'm mary sawwitch i didn't say before
that i'm from hancock
i oppose this bill
because i'm hearing the testimony i
really liked what she just said before
about
all the adverse effects and i just want
to add one little thing um
please look up christine northrup
she was um
probably one of the most noted
gynecologists in the country until
coveted hit
and then
her popularity went down to nothing
she has been seeing
women young women
even older women like menopausal women
bleeding
women that are young um having all
different types of gynecological issues
and i really encourage you to do your
research and look that up because we're
our young people
this vaccine it looks like on the
outside oh i didn't get an effect um
today and tomorrow but you could have
this long-term effect that you won't
find out until
you know you want to bear children
or
anything in the in the future
and it can possibly cause cancer you
don't know what this vaccine could do
so um i've listened to lots of the
alternative the news max and
and um all the different uh
news is that talk about the effects of
this vaccine and i really encourage you
to oppose this
bill thank you thank you very much any
questions
nope that's okay
we're done
and we're going to start the next
hearing in about five minutes i want
everybody have a chance to get up and
foreign
oh yeah
but you know
um
is
i mean i was interested in learning
but i was also interested in having a
social experience that was really
important
dramatically yeah it's something where
um
uh
yes
so kind of as i mentioned in my
testimony uh i have had a back surgery
so i have kind of had a bit of sure
off college experience thus far sure
kind of taken some semesters
off yeah well um this is a good
education yeah
i haven't thought about it all that much
cool um
cool but
hopefully you know we need more young
where do you
um
okay folks we need to get moving here on
this is hb 1637 requiring parents of
public school students to submit a
survey when electing an education
okay representative chase you're here to
present the bill i'm still looking it up
there we go yeah there you are thank you
mr chairman
thank you to the committee for letting
me introduce house bill 1637 today this
bill would require a parent submitting
an application under the education
freedom account if their child was
previously full-time enrolled at a
public school
to um to complete and submit a survey
issued by the department of education
the reason for this survey is in the
bill's language quote
and this is lines i believe five and
seven of the legislation five through
seven um
begins quote the survey shall be
designed by the department for the
purpose of ascertaining the reasons for
the parents election to remove the
student from this public school system
and the parents receive benefits of
utilizing an education freedom account
the survey shall be returned to the
department prior to acceptance into the
fa program and shared with the
administration of the local school
district from which the student is
leaving the reason i introduced this
bill was to help my local school
district and other school districts
across the state figure out why students
would choose to leave public education a
survey will provide school
administrators school boards in the
department of education with vital
information and data that can help
improve public education it will make
public education more responsive to
students needs
if people are obviously leaving you know
our public school system they must have
some kind of perceived you know reasons
why they're leaving they must have a
number of grievances and i think it's
important for for our local policy
makers and state policy makers to really
understand you know why exactly and even
more specific for different school
districts since not every school
district has the same problems as other
school districts and not every school
district has the same benefits as other
school districts um if we do not know
why parents are upset with a specific
school or sau you know it's going to be
tough to actually be able to improve
right i mean part of the reason for the
education freedom accounts was to create
some you know some competition
amongst you know education options and
that was a big reason why myself i did
support the efa program and i still
support the efa program right being
making sure that we have a public school
system that is responsive to students
needs but if school administrators and
school board members and teachers don't
understand why their students are
leaving then it can be pretty difficult
for them to be able to respond to those
students uh their overall needs
additionally the department of education
school districts should find these very
specific trends all the way down to the
specific schools right even
theoretically to specific you know
courses or specific curriculum within
schools school districts or even in
different areas of the state
and so i think it's important that we
collect this data because more data is
going to help us as local and state
policy makers improve education all
education right it's going to help us
improve all education overall some of
the data that's currently collected
right now is mostly by
outside third party groups i think it's
good for public transparency for our
state to be directly collecting this
data so that we know that the data is
clear transparent and that there's no
kind of outside influence because you
could conceivably see you know some
groups that might be anti-efas trying to
collect the data and say you know
students are leaving for you know
unrealistic reasons and some that are
very pro efa saying students are leaving
because public education is terrible i
think we want to get data that's the
most transparent that's the most clear
and that's going to be able to really
inform all of us as to one you know why
people are using efas and what kind of
benefits that they're getting from that
and to
why people feel as if their their public
school systems or their local districts
might be failing them
so with that i'll uh i'll yield to
any well i'll mention one actually one
last thing and one concern that i saw
which i thought was a very good concern
that was brought up by um someone from
nashua was um the anonymity of the
survey and i think it would be a smart
idea for the committee to update it to
make it so the survey is anonymous so
then
people aren't scared about sharing
honest and earnest feedback and i think
the one way to do that would just be to
add before the term survey anonymous
you just added that word you know
throughout the legislation which i think
the term surveys mentioned you know
maybe three or four times i think that
would be a great way to make sure that
you know students who are sharing this
and parents who are sharing this
information don't feel as if that you
know that they can't be earnest and
honest and that they don't feel as if if
they go back to the public school system
that there'll be any kind of you know
perceived retribution um and then we
still get the data overall that uh
people might feel as if it's necessary
to be able to continue improving public
education and address
students needs and with that i'll yield
to any questions thank you are there any
questions representative cordelli
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative
um i'm just
wondering why you're concerned with just
efa students leaving
the school
i think you're familiar with the
governor wentworth district
and
as of october
the enrollment decline was 104 students
but
13 from wolfeboro left for efas
you don't care about why the other 81
students
left
the school oh of course and i think um
if the you know if the committee
believes that we should expand it to all
students leaving the school district but
there's also a question too of of those
104 i mean the vast majority that you're
speaking about left because of either
you know was a decline so it might have
been graduation right some of our
biggest classes are currently i mean
maybe i'm mistaken but um and people may
be moving out of district two
right so there might be a number of
other reasons but i think um if someone
is leaving the district i think that's a
good point i think maybe we should
expand this past jesse of phase
follow-up
thank you um how about if
at the end of the year you survey
all parents
in the school or in the district to see
their satisfaction it could be that
they're living
next year but this way you'll get a full
picture of everyone in the school
and their degree of satisfaction with
their child's education would you
support something like that i saw that
you had a legislation billing for that
and i 100 to support it i think it's a
great idea i think it's good i think
it's good to get everyone's satisfaction
but i think it's also good to know
because you have to
so
and maybe i'm wrong and you can correct
me mr vice chairman but we wouldn't be
able to collect the data for the
students that have already left it would
only be the students that are currently
in the school district i think it's
still important to know why someone has
made that full you know jump into the
program maybe you know maybe i'm
mistaken maybe the committee and other
members can you know um can set me
straight but um i think it's important
for us to get as much data as we can and
if you know between your bill and maybe
an amended version of this bill we could
really maximize that data collection
great
thank you
just
the efa program the current law does not
require
a survey
of parents
as does the tax credit scholarship
program
but
would you believe that i talked to
children's scholarship fund and they
will voluntarily
work with the department and dra to come
up with a survey to send to
efa's
families
i would um i i would certainly believe
that
in working with the department i still i
think there's some merit in
because we don't know how you know i
assume this this this program is going
to exist for an eternity right it's
going to continue to exist as long as we
have a public education system and
theoretically there could be you know
different kinds of groups that end up in
the future you know 50 years from now
operating the program and the program is
definitely going to shift and change
over the next 50 years i think it's good
for us to have in statutory law
some kind of data collection requirement
and for us to be able to collect that
and be able to aggregate that and to
better understand students needs but i
definitely think you know if for the
time being
the scholarship organization working
with the department of education if
they're willing to do that i think
that's a great thing for all students in
our state for the program itself and for
public education i think it's a
win-win-win
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um i noticed when you talked about the
survey and you were talked about
parents grievances
why they were upset
and why the school had failed their
student
um
and it sounds like
[Music]
that that's the only reason people leave
school
and i'm wondering
if
you have any indication
and any assurance to me that the survey
will be
set up a situation where all we hear are
grievances upset parents and failing
students
well i can i wouldn't be able to promise
that because the point of the survey is
to find out grievances um i think the
department and i trust our department of
education would do a fair
job of wording a survey in a way that
would be trying to get you know
objective kind of data but obviously
people are leaving the system are upset
but i think it's important that we find
out why they're upset right and what
exactly their largest um
kind of current complaints are with the
current public education system and how
we can continue to improve public
education to address those concerns
because i think that's you know we need
to recognize public education as
somewhat and this is someone who is a
product of public education it's gotten
fairly stale and in some ways it's not
reaching to every child's potential and
that was part of the reason for the efas
but if we don't have any kind of data of
how to tell our public school systems of
how to improve and why students are
leaving the you know the public
education system and
i think it's going to be more difficult
for us to be able to react and to
respond to the public's demands
yes you may
so it's my understanding
that a large majority of these students
leave the public school and are going to
religious schools
and i would think that if a parent
wanted
their student to have a religious
education in a particular religious
ideology
that that would be
a reason for them to leave
that should be included
and i hope you would agree with me
should be included on this survey rather
than the fact that
they have a grievance or that they're
upset or that they are
the student the public school is failing
thank you
well i'll respond with some
some statistics that i saw in an article
i actually read last night i believe it
was a new hampshire journal that
mentioned um or maybe it was josiah
bartlett um their their policy research
institute were that mentioned that
according to ed choice a big reason why
a number of students in our state are
leaving one of it has to do with covet
protocol but another the second biggest
reason has to do with curriculum right
and feeling as if this students that
they're not being taught to their
potential and so i think that's a big
thing if we have you know i believe
you know right now i'm kind of
estimating based on i'm going based on
memory so please take take with a grain
of salt but um if we have about 30
percent of students that are leaving
because they feel as if they're you know
the parents feel as if their students
aren't being challenged
right i think that's that's a sizable
portion of students
and you know that the public school
system is essentially saying you know
what we you know we have no interest in
being able to challenge our brightest
students so we're going to let some of
our brightest students in our best
performance on standardized tests and
some of our you know students that are
going to be going towards a tall college
degree we're going to let them leave the
public school system because we're not
going to address their concerns i think
the public school system should you know
react and say you know what we want to
keep these students we want to improve
education we want our curriculum to be
you know top notch in the united states
and nationally and i think data like
this is going to help us really you know
understand that and even get feedback
for if it's science it's lacking or math
or reading or writing etc
thank you very much i've got a question
we all know that
folks and parents are always looking for
the best fit for their child be it a
charter school homeschooling
moving with the parent to somewhere else
private schools religious schools et
cetera
efas
but i as a parent
decide to take my child and place them
in an efa
do you think i'm going to give you the
reason why if i have other students in
that same school coming up in the lower
grades and fearful of retribution
towards those students well i take this
out because
uh i don't believe my child would get an
adequate education with teacher x
well i am i certainly and that's why i
think you know it would be wise of the
committee to amend it so that it's an
anonymous survey um then you do run into
the issue of such a small school
district and there's only
two or one yeah two or one so and i do i
do recognize that and um i would i would
i would find it difficult of how to
reconcile it maybe another amendment
would be making it so the information
doesn't just go directly to the
administrators but it just stays with
the department of education for all
students in the state of new hampshire
be aggregated but then it becomes more
difficult to find out how specific
school districts might you know have
certain failings so i mean this is a you
know this is a uh
i wouldn't say at this point that this
bill is ready for prime time after some
of these questions i'll be honest and
i'm willing to admit when i've um when
i'm wrong
but i also think though that it's
important that we collect data i know
the vice chairman is going to have a
good bill that i hope the committee will
unanimously support for collecting data
from these public school students but i
also think it's important to know though
when the students are leaving the public
education system what the biggest
impetus reasons for that are and i hope
that we can find a way in the future to
really ascertain that
okay representative porter then
represent leicester thank you mr
chairman thank you representative for
taking my question um from
sources that i've seen
this year's efa recipients the vast
majority of them were already
homeschooled or in private schools do
you know what percentage of the efa
students
this year are actually leaving their
public schools
i don't have that information i'm sorry
representative no guest with the
number
i'm not going to make i'm not going to
make an educated guess
i just really have no idea
thank you
the department does have that
information
representative coming across the way
represent like us
would you be amenable to this being a
voluntary survey so that those parents
who do fear retribution
will not be held up from
joining this
i think i think that'd be more than fair
i still think that there's a number of
other things though that might need to
be worked out but voluntary making it
anonymous i think those are good steps
in the right direction certainly
thank you
representative ellison thank you mr
chair thanks for taking my question
uh are you aware that
at this point in time 87 percent of the
students who were in school
in new hampshire and public schools i i
was not aware but um if that's that's a
current figure then i would believe it
thank you representative woodcock
thank you mr chairman um probably the
shay that i appreciate you coming
forward with this i didn't i was not
able to discern what dui was actually
going to do with the data because it's
not outlined
but um
that's a different than my point
i take i take exception
to your comment
as a public school employee for a long
time and a teacher
that you made the comment and i quote
referring to public schools we have no
interest in challenging our brightest
students that's what you said
and i think that is a total disregard
for the the
public school teachers
and administrators because they
challenge their students every single
day
and to make that blanket statement i
think it's i think it's um
at least upsetting to me
thank you all right be nice to have a
question you could would you believe and
would you believe you said that um
i'll have to i'll have to rewatch the
youtube recording later but i don't
think that might have been entirely my
direct quote but i was more speaking to
how people are perceiving it
now
i think there are people who might have
that perception whether or not it's true
that's a different story but if people
have that perception i think it's
important for us to address it or at
least to prove
that you know that that
perception might be misguided and that
public schools and public administrators
and teachers are working their hardest
to um to to meet um the needs of
students every student's need
we have a couple more cards are there
any more questions here
from the committee for our
representative
you indicate that you're able to provide
technical support
do you have any testimony that you just
um okay so
there's a couple issues that i just
thought would add to uh
matt why don't you give the organization
oh i'm sorry yeah matt southerton from
children's scholarship fund
there's a couple issues that i think
that the committee would
appreciate knowing we currently collect
this data for the education tax credit
that data is available publicly to
everyone
of course it's non-identifiable data
so
you know
you won't be able to look up the
student's name and
and so that
they wouldn't be able to retaliate
against the students one issue with this
current language is it it's actually as
it's written it's a condition of
enrollment that
we think could be an issue because
currently students can apply for the efa
and they may or may not accept it right
so when we
when we
um share the survey with families
first it's not conditional of acceptance
right
and then secondly they can decide that
they want to fill it out or not
um
and
so
currently
if i looked at the 6 221 survey i found
it interesting 49 of the respondents
uh they just responded as other and then
they put in
individual responses
43 of them said that they chose the etc
because their student was below grade
level
11 and a half because of safety and nine
a little over nine percent because of
special days
so
i don't think they're choosing it
because you know they had a an issue
with the public school per se i think
that they just wanted options that
better fit their student
that was my takeaway and again this is
all available
publicly are there any questions for
matt southerton
yes represent luna
thanks very much mr chair thanks very
much for uh for being with us um uh this
morning um and uh you may have said it
and maybe i missed it but in that survey
were those open-ended questions or were
those options that were given uh
the
there were categories and then there was
an open-ended the other was open-ended
and that was 49
49 was correct so they could yes correct
so so of the 40 of of that 49
could be
um and this is a question so paul um
could be family tradition to attend a
private school it could be family
tradition to be home schooled it could
be change of school because of athletic
opportunities
um you know sports programs not
available in my local school stuff so
i'm looking at one now financial
assistance family of six low-income
sister was already homeschooling so
name omitted joined in with
homeschooling routine
our family was assigned the public
school did not work for my child
uh and you know it goes okay and then
final final question are we going to
fight is this committee going to find
out um um and hopefully sooner rather
than later
uh of the
and i'm looking at the commissioner's
report of the
of the
to do
where's the number
i seem to remember it was like
sixteen hundred
fifty students approximately i think
it's 16.85 yes of the 1685 students how
many students were in
their a public school
during the prior year okay a public
charter school which public school i'd
call that a public school if you want
the prior year home schooled uh the
prior year or in a private or a
non-public school during the uh during
the prior year because the um
the commissioner's
report
indicates that um the expectation was
that 75 percent were going to be coming
from directly from
uh from their public school but at least
based on the commissioner's data it
looks that only 3.6 percent came from
their public school i think this goes to
an earlier question so i think we'd be
very this okay committee would be very
interesting yeah i believe we can pull
uh
representative
mullen thank you mr chair thank you matt
for taking my question
uh if you peruse the other list
do you get a sense that uh giftedness or
a lack of challenge or whatever is on
that list to any
large degree
and i asked that question based on the
fact that we've sat here for years
talking now about uh
the reasons why a student might lead
leave public school but this is one of
the first times that i've heard
giftedness or a lack of challenge or
whatever thank you
i think that i would i would be
speculating i see 268 responses
currently and i i don't know if you'd
want me to review them all in front of
the committee
um
to financially help me afford to send my
child to the school that they love
siblings changed school we were not
comfortable at their that their previous
school
uh
let's see this was two years ago when we
made the decision to switch to school
i wanted to be able to choose the school
that my child would attend
so i think it's it's really about choice
and a lot of it is a financial need
would it be possible to also find out
how many of those students who chose
efas were at some point
enrolled in public schools
because my understanding is
the year before was a big exodus
based on schools not being open and that
wouldn't you know that wouldn't show up
in these numbers in these questions
and then others i believe pulled out
prior to that and were just trying to
make do and that's why they were
homeschooled because public school
wasn't working
and
i don't know if you even have those but
if so could you find that out i believe
we do so when i was looking at the data
approximately half of the students in
the program currently uh have attended a
pri uh have attended a public a
traditional public school before
um but i think we can pull those numbers
forward thank you very much sure are
there any other questions for our
matt
not seeing any hands thank you very much
and kathleen
your handwriting changes from one card
okay hello kathleen cintavi from dover
new hampshire
in reading this bill there are
the word shall
shows up in line four
five and seven
shall is a very strong word that means
that it becomes a requirement
and
i do oppose the fact that this would
become a requirement
however
data is extremely important and i can
tell you just speaking about dover
schools during covid when it was online
parents were told not
to be in the room with their children by
the teachers this is reported to me by
numerous parents
they did not want them in the room but
parents stayed in the room they became
extremely unhappy
with the crt that was being taught
and the fact that pace was very much
slowed down
and i can tell you on my street there
are seven children four of them now go
to private school
as a result of that
and i
did go through the elementary buildings
and
each principal we have three
has a decline of about 100 students per
building
so that is when you have 400 students
that is a big decline in children going
elsewhere
there's private christian academy that
is filled up to the gills
the local catholic school is filled up
they were driving their people their
children down to portsmouth so there
there are a number of things that we
need to start examining i believe in our
public schools so to me
i think that
the idea of an anonymous survey that is
given to each and every student
regardless of the reason why they are
leaving should be done
even in the middle of the year whenever
it is that a child is leaving whether
it's for moving
or for they're going to religious school
or private school home schooling
we need to know
what is going on in our schools and i
can tell you speaking from dover's
perspective parents are not welcome in
the building and they want to know what
is going on they had a glimpse into it
during covid and they were not
happy
so we have to be careful when we're
doing a survey to make sure that it is
not seen as targeting and the number of
parents who spoke with me
said please don't ever
reveal who i am because i'm afraid of
repercussions
for my child so we have to be very
careful and dread tread cautiously but i
do believe that in some form
we need information
otherwise how are we going to turn
things around
thank you very much
are there any questions yes
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question would you it's okay
would you could you remind me again what
organization you represent myself
i'm representing myself not an
organization
yes representing
litchfield thank you um would you mind
repeating your experience though yes i
have over 40 years in teaching i have a
phd in learning and development i have
taught
in middle school high school and
further questions
not seeing you thank you very much
and that concludes
the pink cards we have for this hearing
so we will close this hearing and break
for lunch thank you
uh lunch uh goes through to uh 12 45
when we pick this back up so it's a
shorter lunch today
you
foreign
mr chair
i made myself a cup of coffee in the
office i would like to know who to
reimburse for the water in the little
pod
okay we're going to get ready to go
ahead here for the afternoon's
bills which we have on
on tap here
we have at 12 45 which few minutes ago
was there
hb 1115 is relative to the
record of educational attainment under
the education freedom account program
and i can see we have representative
cornell already at the bench
ready to testify
welcome
thank you good afternoon chair and my
committee
house bill
relative to the record of educational
attendant under the educational freedom
account program
the intent of this bill is actually
accountability and transparency
it requires students who participate in
the education freedom accounts to take
the annual statewide
assessment
this bill
addresses concerns that we heard during
the public hearings for this program
regarding academic accountability
it fall makes sure that we follow the
basic rules of public funds our public
and charter school students take the
statewide assessment and because efa
students receive public funds it's only
fair that they're held to the same
academic accountability requirements
hbill1115 does not require any minimum
score or performance to continue
participating in the program it's just
to help see if
students are doing equally as well
better
whatever in the um private or
religious schools where they are using
thank you you're welcome are there any
questions from the committee
representative lakas
yes many times you have said to us that
this one exam is not a good assessment
and we really need broader assessments
etc
which is why these three different
assessments were put in there and you
can still see progress my concern comes
i know that
a number of the students in the efa
program are special needs students
some of these a portfolio is a much
better
way of
seeing progress than the standardized
test and some of them probably have
difficulties
with that test
thank you for the question i think the
same accommodations would be made for
students getting the efas in private
schools that are made for the students
that are taking those tests in the
but what about home school students they
don't have an iep or any of that kind of
stuff
um
and that's and and the portfolio has to
be looked at by a certified teacher
or a teacher currently teaching in a
non-public school
so they're still getting
and they're still getting an assessment
done
but that way
the parent can choose the assessment
that makes the most sense and for some
kids the other i mean
when my son for the
my youngest son was homeschooled and i
did the statewide assessment because it
was cheap easy and quick
and i knew how he was doing and so i you
know i assessed him all the time
some of the kids who do have some
serious learning disabilities
that would be not the best
assessment
is that a question
all students in all public and charter
schools take this test so i think to be
equal accor across the board measuring
achievement
all students should take the same test
a public school student can't say i'm
going to submit a portfolio instead
instead of taking this chess test
thank you
representative mullen
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question representative
cornell is there anything in your bill
that would prevent a student from also
keeping a portfolio to demonstrate their
performance or competencies
no
that's nothing like that in the bill at
all
any further questions from the committee
is this a way to make
the looking at schools and how effective
they are
um
apples to apples uh so that you have
like
assessments is that what the intent is
uh yes representative moffatt thank you
mr thank you for taking my question and
uh as you may know i'm sympathetic to
assessments i really think there's a
place for them so i'm really intrigued
by this my question is
homeschoolers
the
efas can go to homeschoolers
so
would this measure apply to
homeschoolers
you know i have to think about that
because right now homeschoolers
aren't under the same
as
thank you
representative mullen
thank you representative cordelli
representative cornell would you believe
that when i was a school counselor
somewhat recently
homeschoolers used to come to school
we would send out a notice saying that
the state assessment was being given
and we had any number of home school
students join us at school to take the
state assessment there
so
that that's always an option as well
it is thank you
representative porter
thank you mr chair representative
cornell maybe this is unfair because you
have eliminated the language
in
the current law
by filing this bill i'm especially
looking at
what would be lines 10 through
14 about the portfolio
my reading of that is that
i have i'm a certified teacher in early
childhood education
and if i'm reading this right it would
be permissible for parents
of a high school chemistry student to
use my knowledge to approve
or express the performance of their
child because i am a certified teacher
is that how you read that
is that
i'm not sure are you talking about the
part
yes that's one of the reasons why you
might have taken it out the portfolio
rather than
partly but partly because
to fairly have accountability and
transparency i think everybody should be
are there further questions represented
litchfield
thank you for taking the question and
thank you
i just wanted to clarify something
right now in the public school are you
able to opt out can a parent have a
i think so but i think the school is
responsible for making sure that 95
i'm i'm not 100 sure
recently recently retired myself not
that many do opt out in a public school
yes you may
thank you um i just i've noticed in our
district over the past couple years that
many parents have started to opt out
more and more i'm assuming it's the
state assessment that they're opting out
of my question is regarding this bill is
this also going to have private schools
be required to administer the assessment
as well if they're getting the efa yes
wow okay thank you
just the point of clarification for 95
you're correct but that is a federal
requirement with our application for the
monies which we're seeking out we try to
hit that when you get down below there
okay further
thank you for taking my question um i'm
not really sure if i'm going to form
this question correctly
but if we have say a charter school
or a charter schools or public schools
so i guess that would really wouldn't it
wouldn't matter in that case but
private schools may choose to use
different curriculum
to achieve the same standards
in the statewide assessment
would it be possible for say
i'm just going to go back to like
everyday math
um
for those types of questions to be on
the statewide assessment that say maybe
a
private school
wouldn't use
am i making sense is that a clear
question
is that a clear question
i i think so but i i think the material
that gets assessed is the material
that's supposed to be covered in that
grade so whether you're in a private
school
public charter
religious school it should all be
covering the same material in the same
grade
yes
so specifically i'm thinking of say a
different curriculum
being used to achieve the same standards
the same competencies may look different
in a
in a private school than in a public
school and would that cause
as i said my son when he when we use
this
we just let the school do the test
because it was like i said faster
cheaper and easier and he could always
ace him so and you know one
got it over with quickly and easily for
me but
and i would have to set up a special
thing with the
guidance counselor to be able to do it
and it has as an option
a nationally standardized norm
referenced achievement test and that was
put in because a lot of the private
schools use a different test
it's still an assessment test
and um
so i'm wondering are we going to have
all these kids who don't even have i
mean it was easy for me because he'd
been in the school for five years
and they knew him and it was easy to set
up a test
and the guidance counselor knew him and
you know wasn't particularly worried
about it right but
are we gonna then have all these kids
you know have to
come up with some way i know
homeschoolers who have been keeping a
portfolio and have a teacher and as the
kids got older they picked a different
teacher
who was more appropriate for the age at
which the kids were at
how are we going to deal with this if
we're making them all take this
statewide assessment which isn't given
annually
this is the test that's given annually
it is given annually
this is the statewide assessment test
that is given every year
okay so not the other test that you take
in the third eighth
and eleventh okay thank you
i do have one question for you and i
i'll try not to get down into the weeds
too much on standardized testing
and um
looking at some of those scores which we
oftentimes oftentimes the the public
likes to see a percentile score
which is really uh not a score which i
as the school administrator wanted to
look at all the time
uh there are other scores like a stay
nine i won't i don't want to look at
that either but there are some scores
which show you that
if you're taking the old-fashioned gates
mckinney reading test or the iowa test
of basic skills or the california test
any of them there are some scores which
parallel between them normal curve
equivalent and then you can look at some
growth scores as well so is there any
reason why you have eliminated the
national standardized norm reference
achievement test which has those scores
which are very comparable and relate
between
the statewide tests that we give here
and
the achievement test which is nationally
normed and has the nce scores and all
that which we can compare
i guess my thought was just that it
would be
more um
transparent
more
easily looked at if everybody took the
same test okay thank you
representative tanner
the
tests that the
the state of new hampshire allows as a
testing level i know at the high school
level sats were one of them
wouldn't they be the same for everybody
in the united states
uh whether they were home schooled
private schooled or whatever if you're
if you have to take an sat test to get
into college for college entrance it it
effectively covers
the general
level of competency
in language and math and whatever
uh across the board so it wouldn't it be
a better
whatever we use in the public schools uh
the knee app or the sat
if we use that across the board then we
could it would be a level playing field
and we would see we could compare apples
to apples and oranges to oranges isn't
that
what this is about yes
thank you
i got another pursuing question then
wouldn't you believe that
either the s.a.t or the act
aren't even required by 70 of our
colleges now wouldn't it be better then
that we use a nationally normed
reference test somewhere in the high
school level to give us this information
that you're looking for
seeing that the sat is no longer
okay don't worry
any further questions
i've got a question for you represent
luna yes thanks thanks very much um and
mr chair during during a comment you
made earlier i just want to follow up
with it because i think um i think it's
it would be good for the committee to
other members to
understand it you talked about how a
norm reference test um outcome could
somehow be compared with with that of um
of the sat or a statewide assessment
yeah i'm not referencing the sat at all
i'm representing another
achievement norm reference achievement
test but but so so specifically i
thought i heard you say
the the statewide achievement tests that
other
students in public schools are taking
and that a norm reference test could
could be
measured an outcome on a norm reference
test could be measured
comparably to that so that and i think
you use the term apples to apples if if
you're using the right type of
comparative data
from that test
you don't want to take your percentile
score but if you take another
score which is designed around
what we're trying to achieve here in
terms of looking at
two different achievement tests you can
do it it's not just a percentile against
a certain
number of students that are above or
below within that particular group
that's taking it in your school
um
and that's that's uh
what i'm what i said was that it you can
compare
data from an iowa test a california test
any of those achievement tests
if you use the proper
testing data
you wouldn't use a percentile score to
do that
you'd use something like a normal curve
equivalent score
and i can see
there's a lot of test and measurement
information out there that i think that
at this particular committee uh
we would have to get
you know uh people that are familiar
with it to really get a good
understanding here right right well we
have have that you know college class
under our belts and even at that time
yeah yeah
no thanks thank you but you can compare
achievement tests to achievable i'm sure
i'm sure you can i oftentimes did it
with the case mckinney and with an
achievement test in the area of reading
or comprehension okay
okay great thank you yes representative
porter
thank you mr chair uh representative one
of the things that we hear a lot is that
with the federal money comes
is it your intent with this bill
that if
state money is going to an ins a
provider an education provider that they
also have some requirements
that they have to
uphold in order to keep receiving
i don't know i
didn't say in the bill that it would
result in their losing the money or not
it just
that they should take the same um
achievement tests it won't they won't
lose their money if the students don't
do well on it no but would it be a
requirement in receiving an efa student
that they'd give this test because
they're receiving state money with that
student yes
not yes represent litchfield
i'm sorry
i'm trying to figure out a way to wrap
three and one and i don't know how i'm
just trying to understand it so
if you're saying that the results of the
test they don't i don't want to say they
don't matter because that's not a
correct way to put it but
what's the point of them taking the test
what is the end goal here
i think a lot of the arguments for efas
were students were not doing well in
their public school and they want to go
to a private school where they will do
where they do much better and this would
be a way of measuring
um are they doing better in the private
school
yes
so we are going to use the results then
and are they not anonymous too at that
point
i'm just trying to understand i have
children in public and private school
and the beauty of a private school is it
is accredited and i trust that they're
going to do a good job and you know
people argue do you teach to the test i
don't worry about any of that the kids
don't have to deal with that so my
question is i'm just trying to
understand what is the point of giving
an assessment if we're not going to do
anything with it but now i feel like i'm
hearing you say that yes we are going to
use it to measure the private schools
we're going to use it to measure the
students that are getting the efa if
they're if they are achieving
just compare to themselves
okay so maybe just one more sure is
there would there be a financial note
with this though who would who would
it would be part of the private school
program
it would be paid by the state
because it's already agreed that you
know you can bring a kid and get the
test
from a private school to the resident
represent nelson
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question you mentioned that
private schools would lose the money how
about public schools i never said
anything about losing money i thought it
was discussed that if a private school
didn't reach a certain thing they would
lose their money from the state coming
oh more questions
it's your day you hit the jackpot it
represents like us
i'm still
i guess i'm still wondering how you're
going to deal with the special needs
kids because as we heard an awful lot of
the kids who do
and they may be homeschooled not private
schooled
um
how are you gonna do like
i know home school kids who are
extremely dyslexic and their spelling is
something that you wouldn't even
it's challenging to read
but
they are phenomenal in chemistry which
isn't tested on the standardized test
phenomenal in electricity and magnetism
which isn't tested and i'm wondering and
their progress is slow i mean we see
from year to year they get a little
better but in the percentiles they may
not get better they may look like
they're getting worse compared to their
classmates
but compared to themselves
they they are slowly getting better at
spelling but it's because they're very
dyslexic and that's a learning
disability
and i'm wondering i still don't
understand how you're going to deal with
that that was part of the point of the
portfolios
because then they're not taking this
standardized test they're able to
display their work
and say
see the progress i've made
and progress in all kinds of fields that
aren't even tested so you can see
they're learning a lot
even if their spelling is very slow and
improving
so that's how are you going to deal with
them that's my question
accommodations for testing can be in the
iep
but homeschool kids don't have an iep
that's my point
how do you deal with them
because that's a lot of homeschoolers
are special needs kids
i i think what we can do is some of this
can be discussed during executive
session i i don't think we need to
rattle through all this right now
um there's
getting in the area of special education
there's a lot of alternative ways of
assessing a child that's in special ed
including not giving the statewide
assessment
and there's alternatives so we can
discuss that in executive session when
we get there
are there any remaining questions for
representative cornell
okay we have uh
sarah scott from the americans for
prosperity
all right thank you mr chairman and
members of the committee for the
opportunity to testify here
my name is sarah scott and i'm the
director of grassroots operations with
americans for prosperity new hampshire
and on behalf of afp new hampshire and
our activists all across the state
we urge you to
oppose house bill 1115 which changes the
assessment requirements for students
participating in the education freedom
accounts program
under the legislation that was passed
last year efa students have three
options for assessment that are in line
with the requirements that we have
currently for home educated students
this bill would take away two of those
options and force parents and schools
into a single assessment that is
inconsistent with our currently approved
options
right now students who are in a private
school are already taking approved
assessments and students who are
educated at home are also fulfilling an
approved assessment requirement
there's no reason to test efa students
any differently than we do the students
who are at accredited schools or who are
home educated
this legislation would really just
create an unnecessary burden for
families and educators who are already
working hard to stay compliant with
assessment requirements
and kids really learn in so many
different ways and providing multiple
options for assessment really ensures
that we are more accurately able to
review
student achievement and also remain
consistent with the current assessment
requirements we have across the board
if efas lead to new education models
outside of the accredited schools
approved state programs and home
education
then we could revisit testing models at
some point but right now i think this is
premature
all of our approved education options
have a system in place already to review
student achievement so it's for these
reasons that we ask that you oppose this
bill
and happy to take questions thank you
very much are there any questions
perhaps
thank you very much excuse me thank you
very much mr chair
thank you very much miss scott a couple
times you just mentioned um
um uh people that are quoting i think i
got your quote right already working
hard to be in compliance with assessment
requirements i was wondering if you
could tell us what those assessment
requirements are that they're already
working hard on so the current
assessments uh for home educated
students in particular is what i'm
referencing um there are the three
options and especially a lot of students
do the portfolio review and they're very
diligent throughout the year to keep
track of all of their work and put
together
we're not talking like a couple of pages
here they're fairly substantial binders
of work okay so follow-up so you're
talking about
these
requirements that are in place right now
for home school
students
who are not part of the the efa program
obviously the requirement here is for
students that are participating in the
efa program so so the question would be
do you feel that that accountability
in
accountability and transparency is
important in a any program that uses
taxpayer dollars
i think we already have systems systems
in place for all of the approved options
and i don't see why an efa student would
be tested any differently than we test
representative porter and then
representative
tanner thank you mr chair i'm going to
ask my question again
to you because you obviously know more
about how things are working
i have a certificate
in early childhood education
could a parent use me to assess the
portfolio for their high school
chemistry student
thank you for that question
so um i don't know specifically i would
assume it is probably legally allowed
but typically parents choose somebody
that is in line with
the student's progress
parents do use these assessments and
portfolio reviews as their own
assessment they don't do it just to
do you have any statistics on that
i don't believe any statistics are
collected
thank you
representative tanner
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my questions
um
how do you think
the public can be assured
that
without
without public view of assessment and
and like you do with the public schools
that their public funds
are being spent the way they're supposed
to be spent and effectively and
efficiently
um
because i don't think those other
assessments or the assessments of the
efa program
the private schools or the
homeschoolers
that there's a public accounting
of what happens with those assessments
each year like there is for the public
schools uh thanks for the question so i
would just say that um in particular for
the students who are doing a portfolio
review
a certified teacher does have to review
it and
acknowledge that the student is
at academic levels that they should be
so i think we're really trusting that
the teachers we've certified through the
state are accurate in their assessments
of the students performance
yes
my question was more about
transparency and accountability for the
public
because now we're using public funds
to support these programs
you know
rather than a home school program before
where we didn't have public funds
supporting them
and every year
the public school system
has
there is published at the doe and also
in a lot of papers
the results of assessments uh aggregate
assessments
for schools and often schools are
compared one against the other about how
their achievement scores are
whether they're above or below in math
we use those we use the data here in in
the education
committee to make certain decisions
and i'm just wondering how
how you feel we could
use the current assessment program
and assure the public
with transparency
that uh the the prog our money is being
spent efficiently effectively and that
students are actually learning
uh i think that by showing the public
that these students did achieve at grade
level we've done our part to ensure
transparency and that the education for
further questions represent cordelia
thank you mr chairman thank you
miss scott for being here
since one of the
testing options that is being eliminated
is the portfolio similar to what is in
place
for homeschool children
do you have any information on
achievement levels for home school
students
so thank you for the question in all of
the studies that have been done
homeschool students have consistently
ranked above
many other education options
i know a number of homeschoolers do take
the
nationally recognized standardized tests
and in the information that's been
collected for those the students have
consistently ranked among the top
students
further questions represent luna sure
thank you very much mr chair um that's
very interesting uh thanks for bringing
that up does the department of education
uh collect that information and provide
it for comparison purposes
the students that take the nationally
recognized test that's
collected by the testing service not by
the new hampshire department
so there's no way to validate what so
let me say it another way how did you
come across this information
uh this is just based on studies that
have been done that are out there in the
public that you can look back at just to
see how um homeschool students have
traditionally ranked amongst other
students across the country all up to
that
so how did those studies acquire the
information that was collected by
private testing companies
these testing companies often do ask
students
what their
education model is some public schools
do use these nationally recognized tests
as well so some of that
you do usually give the information that
it is either you're at a public school
private school or home educated
final follow-up could you please email
the committee with the with how we can
find that information specifically where
that information is for
school for home school students
that take a um
a private assessment uh assessment test
and how that data can be compared to
public school students sure absolutely
are there any further questions
maxine yes represent hobson
thank you for taking my question of
sarah scott and thank you for allowing
me to
um
it was my understanding when the efa
program was established that
i guess it's going through the
children's scholarship fund that we
would be able to
look at the expenses of maybe audit
isn't the right word
down to the pencil and i'm wondering is
that information available to the public
or is that information specific to
maybe the department of ed do you know
the answer to that question i don't have
the answer to that i do believe that the
majority of that information is public
but i could be wrong on that
further questions don't see any hands
thank you very much
uh mr southerntown are you going to
testify in this one that there's a card
up here
um
see that that is
this bill
do no you're going to pass on it okay
so i don't have any other cards up here
at this time on this bill so we're going
would you believe
you
you got us talking representative
cornell
so
so what we'd like to do is go on to the
next bill which we have in the docket
here
what's the number we got
one three seven six
go for it thank you
good afternoon representative cornell
representing ward 11
district 18 in manchester
um i have an amendment should i address
the amendment which corrects
the rsa that i wanted to replace
can you address the the uh the original
bill as you introduced it and and then
also indicate where you would like to
propose changes and provide
a proposed amendment to the committee
when we just when we own it
okay
so
house bill 1376
um
it's the education freedom accounts and
it's the intent of it is to make sure
that
parents who place their children in a
private school and with taking education
freedom accounts know that they waive
their special education rights under
idea
so the amendment that i put in
corrected i had rsa 194
dash b colon 4 and it should be 194-f
and what i
want to say is that a child
participating in a publicly funded
education freedom account program
forfeits the rights for a free and
appropriate education or fape
this is because parts participation in a
voucher program
amounts to a parental placement under 20
usc section 1412 small a 10 capital a
presently
school
voucher or efa programs do not always
adequately inform parents of the
consequence they should receive advance
notice of that consequence that a child
forfeits the rights to a free and
appropriate education while
participating in the efa program
that's the whole bill that's it that's
it thank you very much are there
questions for representative cornell
representative cordelli
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative
um
this
efas are not not vouchers
so
there are not
there's not a voucher given to a student
to attend a particular
let's say private school
so
efa funds
can be used for a whole range of options
private school placement because this
bill refers to
a parental placement in a private school
which does not encompass
all efa students
so would you see that as an
issue i don't think so because i think
if a parent places their school in the
private program and then uses the efa to
pay for part of that
they
could be giving up their rights um they
could be forfeiting their rights to
special ed under idea so i think this is
just notifying the parents that that may
happen
you follow
but if they do not place their child in
a private school
but take a from the list of
other educational options
um i don't think any of that falls into
your bill your bill is assuming doesn't
it that
all students would be placed in a
i think it's just
referring to students that are placed in
and i i think there'll be people someone
speaking after me who can address it
better than i can
okay
um
and
do you think that
the
language about waiving
rights is correct
in that
at any point
a student
could go back into a public school or a
public charter school
and resume
being covered by ida so they're really
not
waiving rights
they may be waiving their rights while
they're in the private school
if they went back to the public or the
public charter school
they would be
covered again
follow up
but
children in a private school
as you indicate here are covered under
uh usc section 1412 etc so they are
um
they
they are not waiving rights under idea
because as stated in lines four through
five
they are covered
when they place their student in a
private school
under
is that is that correct
no
because the way it reads is they receive
notice that participation in the efa
program is a parental placement under 20
usc section
1412 individual so they receive if they
do place them there they receive notice
that participation is a parental
placement
so the parent is placing them in the
private school
and they may waive their rights to a
representative
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
is it not true
that
there has been concern over
parents just assuming that the private
school that they placed their child in
would pick up their special ed services
by virtue of the fact that the student
had an iep or a 504 plan when they were
in the public school
and uh
it does is this bill not in response to
that that parents thought that the kids
were going to receive services when
they weren't going to because it was
a unilateral decision
yes
further questions
represent tanner
yes uh thank you for taking my question
i'm wondering about
schools like prenda and also uh schools
that are only for tuition purposes only
uh if if some if a parent had took an
efa and placed their student in one of
those two
uh groups
uh would they then waive their right for
prenda is the the third part yeah
yeah i'm not sure about printed because
i i really don't know enough about the
rules of prenda but
um
i i think
basically it's the private school that
they're placed into so if prenda is
considered a private school under these
rules
rep san luna thank you very much mr
chair is the um
representative cornell is the intent of
this bill
to make um like a material change to the
to the efa program or is it to provide
clarity and transparency so that
families know what they're getting into
it's simply to provide clarity that
parents realize when they're placing
their child in the school they may be
giving up their rights to a free and
further questions
uh bonnie can you turn the red light on
press the button
okay yes thank you
apparently no i could not um so
thank you um i'm here in support of this
bill and i appreciate so much the
sponsors introducing it
and then providing additional clarity
through the amendment that they've
proposed
i think that this bill will help to
ensure that parents of students with
disabilities who choose to enroll in the
efa program do so with a clear
understanding of how that participation
will affect their child's rights under
idea
if a parent enrolls their child with a
disability who has an efa in a public or
private nonprofit elementary or
secondary school that meets the
definition established by the state
then that child is considered to be a
parentally placed private school child
with a disability
if the parent places their child in a
for-profit private school or homeschools
their child
or in any setting that is not does not
meet the definition of an elementary or
secondary school
under state law then that child is not a
parentally placed private school child
with a disability they're just a child
with a disability
the child who is in a for-profit private
school or is homeschooled because they
are not a parentally placed private
school child with a disability has no
right to special education at all the
parentally placed private school child
which is a child who was placed by their
parent in a non-profit
public or private elementary or
secondary school
does have some
group right to
a free appropriate public education or
to some services under idea
and that's because
of the equitable services requirement in
idea and that requirement says that the
school district the lea must spend an
amount proportionate to the amount of
idea funds or the federal funds the lea
receives for the group of parentally
placed private school students with
disabilities attending private
elementary or secondary schools in the
school district served by the lea
so whatever amount of federal funds that
the school district gets for that group
of students they must spend on that
group of students
but only if that child is in a placement
that meets the definition of an
elementary or secondary school which
means a non-profit elementary or
secondary school public or private
doesn't matter
because children who are not parentally
placed private school children with
disabilities
if they are in a not in a for-profit or
are in a homeschool situation the lea
does not receive any idea funds for
those students so the equitable
calculation the calculation for the
proportionate share of equitable
services is not applicable you can't
have an equitable proportion of money
that doesn't exist
i guess zero of zero is zero the lea
does continue for all of those children
for every child
with a disability who is in their
catchment area
they're still responsible for child find
activities and so a parent can make an
initial referral
if their child had an iep and then they
choose to re rejoin the public system
they can again have their child be found
eligible for special education and all
of the rights remain intact
for that child once they are determined
to con that they continue to be a child
with a disability
and they are in that public system
so the distinction between a child with
a disability
who is and who is not considered to be a
parentally placed private school child
with a disability can be confusing and
that was in the original statute so this
this amendment um
doesn't doesn't confuse doesn't
conflagrate those those that was already
um confusing in the original statute
that was passed a couple of years ago
because those those are two separate
situations children who are and children
who are not parentally placed private
school children with a disability so
because it's confusing it's really
really important that parents of
children with disabilities regardless of
where they're going to be placing them
if they have an efa have a clear
understanding get a clear and
user-friendly explanation of what rights
under idea they will no longer have and
what rights they they may still have
i because of the confusing nature of
that i do hope that the department of
education
is given the authority to either
write or approve whatever explanation is
developed that is provided to those
parents thank you
are there questions for
bonnie dunham
representative cordelli
thank you thank you for being here um
so just
um going back to my original line of
questioning
a child with an efa who was placed in a
non-public school according to law
is still covered by idea
but a different portion a different
section of idea as as if they had been
in a public school is that correct
a child who was in a private school is
considered to be a parentally placed
private school child if that private
school is a non-profit elementary or
secondary
school if it is not they are not the
section of idea that
that
applies to those student is the one that
explains how school districts do not
have to use state or local funds to pay
for it so it's a particular section and
in fact in the regulations they clarify
that by saying
that
no parentally placed private school
child with a disability has an
individual right to receive some or all
of the special education and related
services that the child would receive if
go follow up
so
if they are
getting an efa and placed in a
non-public school by their parent they
are still covered by ida is that correct
is it a non is it a non-profit yes it's
an approved non-public school by the
state then they are covered by the
section of idea that says they have no
yes
no individual
okay
that gets into the whole how you
calculate what percentage of funds uh
title one funds that the uh
non-public school will receive to
provide services for that child under an
individual service plan
so if they're is that correct
sort of if there are ten students with
disabilities enrolled in a private
school
then the school that in the school
district would have to use the funds
that came in for those 10 students on
those 10 students but if nine of those
students need reading help then the
school district could choose to spend
all of the money on a reading specialist
to support those children on a part-time
basis the one child who does not need
reading support even though they are a
child with a disability may get no
further
so
if they're all 10 students are in a
public school
and the school
chooses to give reading services
to nine children all using up all those
funds
the one child in the public school
who has needs
eliminated from receiving any special
needs funds did you mean to say public
school no private right in
a public in excuse me in a pro
non-public school
yes yes they are not entitled to the
school district has to engage in
meaningful and timely consultation with
the private schools so that they can
make a
decision about how they can best expend
those funds and my
understanding is that they do their best
to give children something but if
financially and and consulting with
everyone it turns out that that is
that the way to best use those funds is
that one child will be left out yes one
child would be left out
so your position is in looking at idea
that the public
school district does not have to provide
funds under idea to that child in a
non-public school
that has a service plan that has been
agreed to they wouldn't have a service
plan a service plan is only for those
students who through me timely and
meaningful consultation the school
district decides to expend funds on idea
funds on the children who do not get
services do not have a services plan i
provided the entire section of idea in
my written testimony where you can read
that
further questions
representative porter
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you bonnie for taking my question i
really want to thank you for what you
sent to us um it helped to help me to
understand what was going on here
so let me see if if i've got it right
the federal government sends school
districts money
for their
idea kids
okay
if 10 of those kids
go to a private school
this the prac the public school takes
the money for those 10 kids and can use
and shares it out with those kids that
are in the private school is that right
they spend it on that group of students
it's a little more complicated because
the school district that gets those
funds is the school district in which
the private school is located it has
nothing to do with where the child lives
the child could live in
san francisco and be attending a school
in new hampshire or private school
and the school district where the
private school is located would get the
idea funds for that child they really
complicated it the last time they
revised idea so can i have a follow-up
then so the public school the kids who
the cost of those services to those kids
over and above what the federal
government sends is what's absorbed by
the local taxpayers and by the state yes
so once those kids are out of the public
school
under
the idea
law
they are no longer
public schools are no longer required to
use their
property tax money and the state money
to fund the services for the kids in the
private school
the only thing they're responsible for
is the money that comes from the feds
yes is that right thank you very much
further discussion
yes representative
go ahead thank you bonnie for coming
because you're really making a lot of
this clear to us and i still have
in trying to understand this you've
explained the private schools very well
and i think i get what's going on there
what if a parent places a student in
another public school that's not in
their district what happens in that case
it all it's all based on whether or not
the school is considered to be
a
an elementary or secondary school under
idea new hampshire may have some wanky
things that i'm not aware of where
they may decide that placement in a
public school would carry some
additional pieces just like a parent
could tuition a child to a public school
another public school
and through an arrangement that's made
and i'm really not sure
i don't think that this statute is clear
enough on that issue
for me to be able to answer that
question
my understanding is that it
would be treated as if they placed them
in
you know they made a unilateral
placement
thank you very much
i think that has to be looked at a
little bit it does i think i i'm saying
i think we're
not interpreting it maybe the way does
interpreting it right now or as an efa
that
fourth leg of the stool
um there's you know more to the story
than we're getting at right here right
yes and the u.s department of ed through
their office of special ed programs
keeps issuing guidance on this issue and
many issues because
some things are not clear enough in the
beginning and the work needs to be done
to make them more clear
representative luna thank you very much
mr chair and thank you very much miss
tom but but would you would you say
though that the language that's been
provided here and
particularly in the amendment that was
handed out for 39
um uh doesn't
um
doesn't change the responsibility that
that public or private
schools have or that the federal
government has but clarifies uh
substantially over what is in current
law yes it doesn't change any of the
of the responsibilities of the school
district or the rights of the parents it
just makes sure that they are aware of
what those rights are what rights they
retain and what rights they don't retain
and how that whole process would work
you know how a school district would
decide how to spend that federal
money on that group of students because
it really is a confusing thing
represent porter thank you and i don't
mean to put you on the spot bonnie book
can you give us
why do you know all this good
information you have
an organization that you're representing
i work at the parent information center
i'm here as a private citizen because as
a parent of a child with a disability
we all find each other and so i know a
lot of other parents of children with
disabilities some who have chosen to
homeschool their children
some who have chosen to place them
privately with or with with
through the school district and some
unilaterally um and i
am aware of just how often parents
make decisions based on incomplete or
inaccurate information
and then end up being sorry and having
to go back and fix what problem has been
created and so i just feel very strongly
as a parent that parents need to have
accurate information so they can make
informed decisions whatever those
decisions may be i might disagree but
bonnie has worked with special education
ever since i can remember
and on task force now i can just
remember all the times we've worked
together bonnie and this so her
expertise is
it goes down deep
my son was born with a disability 41
years ago and when he was two i started
taking classes and i hung out so often
at those classes that one day they said
do you want to stay we'll pay you and i
okay are there any more questions to ask
of bonnie dunham
much let's see
okay so we are done that one right now
and we'll get ready to go into the next
hearing here which starts in about two
you
we're at hb6 uh 1670 right now relative
to funds of the education freedom
account program after termination of a
student's participation and
responsibilities of the scholarship
organization
and
we have represented bonnie hamm no
yes
mask i can't see through the mass
there no no you don't don't take it off
i'm just saying
press the silver button
there you go
hi there i am representative bonnie ham
i represent lincoln woodstock in
waterville valley
and i am here to introduce and support
house bill 1670 which is a bill relative
to funds of the education freedom
account program after termination of a
student's participation
in the program and responsibilities of
basically if i feel and and this bill um
states that if a student chooses to stop
participating in an education fund
account program for any reason there can
be a number of reasons
that that could happen
that
subsequent payments
and further expenditures should
terminate upon
that student choosing not to participate
in the education
whether they go back to the public
school whether there's been misuse of
the funds or whether they've
have another idea for their education
the state of new hampshire should not
continue to support
his education fund
account any further
and so the money should stop the flow of
money should stop both payments
and expenses that we pay out
now if the student decides to go back in
to the program at a later date
then
the student can reapply
and funding will resume
so
to me it just
makes sense that we shouldn't be sending
money
to a program that the student isn't
participating in
and it further requires
an audit
of
the individual's account
and or random audit audits of the
program in general
to make sure that the funds are being
used
appropriately
and i'm open to any questions or further
explanations of
my idea for a bill
thank you very much representative ham
are there
questions
reps and lakers
thank you
if in in in law already it says that the
funds will immediately be suspended but
parents often first they have to
apply
they have to get permission from the
scholarship organization to spend
anything
then they may have to
order etc whatever it is that they're
trying to get which sometimes can take
some time
and then off and then
sometimes they actually have to pay up
front for that item
and then eventually once they submit the
receipt then they get reimbursed and i'm
wondering what happens to the parent
who's caught in the middle of that
if they've gotten the okay
put in the order potentially paid out of
pocket
counting on that money coming in from
and they've been in the program like it
says here at least a year so it's an
ongoing thing
and then decide for whatever reason that
actually they're going to put the kid
back in public school are they can they
still be reimbursed for that okayed
expense that they incurred while the
student was
an afa student or
are they now on the hook for that
in my opinion and i don't know if this
bill states it
adequately certainly
anything that was ordered
as part of the educational opportunity
the child was participating in
should be reimbursed and i do agree
there can be a delay
in
getting bills paid and so forth but um
i would think
that and i would welcome any language
that made it clear
if any expenditure that had to do with
his his educational opportunity while he
should be reimbursed
but
certainly
the year if the child is in the program
six months and
you know we shouldn't be paying for
bills for the
uh
second sixth month the year the year um
one of the key things in here is that
year
that year if we could somehow word it so
that we are
legitimately reimbursing for
expenses for the opportunity he
participated in and received
and didn't
pay for
other items
that had nothing to do with the
educational weapon opportunity he
enjoyed
i would welcome any amendment that
whoops thank you very much
thank you
further further questions
so thank you thank you very much mr
chair and um
and uh and thank you very much um um uh
representative ham for for bringing 1670
forward this afternoon
one of the things that um that that this
committee has wrestled with a little bit
is the um
is the the the language in here that um
where um where uh misuse of funds misuse
of funds must be intentional and
substantial
and
uh and i was wondering if you could talk
with us a little bit about um
about maybe
you know why intentional is something
the attorney general would investigate
and substantial would be something the
scholarship organization would determine
if you know
the words intentional
have been
deleted
they have that change has been suggested
and i think it's because pretty hard
to
prove intent
you know
we really don't want to go there we just
don't want to pay for
uh expenses that weren't part of the
education received
so that the word intentional was deleted
was retained
and
[Music]
you notice substantial is a word used in
several places substantial
misrepresentation
substantial misuse
um and and i would say uh when they
drafted this
um
that
that's kind of indicating to me
that well perhaps it isn't worthwhile to
chase down
fifty dollars you know i don't know what
dollar amount you'd wanna use but
i think that's to indicate
substantial you know the definition of
substantial
something that's worthwhile
something that's a number big enough
that's worth um
going after or trying to recapture or
whatever not
not a dollar not fifty dollars
and there again maybe there might be
need to be some clarification
or a definition of substantial but this
isn't to
to to take parents and students
to court or go after them or
or turn this into a bad experience
this is just to
recapture some state funds
that
might be outlaid
with no value
thank you very much
representative woodcock
thank you chairman live
good afternoon uh thank you thank you
for taking my question just let me show
i understand the particular part dealing
with lines 19 and 20.
i'm talking about the change from may to
shell
so if i understand this bill correctly
every student that does withdraw
from the efa during the time of the
their account the account is frozen
except for the types of bills you talk
with president weakest but their their
account will be all audited yes okay
that's what it means okay thank you so
much thank you representative you're
welcome any further questions
bonnie i i have one question for you on
the other page it's kind of a
just a technical type thing on line 14
on page two
you talk about notifying the parent
within five business days
it takes about five days believe it or
not for a letter to get from haverhill
to concord
um
it's all downhill that's right
um so is that just a number that
somebody selected or could it be
extended like to 10 days
sure that was just a number as opposed
to as quickly as possible which could
mean anything
could be months could be whatever i
think uh we tried to
put a number to it meaning quickly
quickly not two months later so i mean
certainly five days um
is is a tough uh bar
to maintain or even ten maybe ten or two
weeks or something or something prompt a
notice not not let this hanging for
months okay thank you uh further
questions
doesn't look like we have any more
questions thank you very much thank you
very much for this opportunity
you know that's
that that is grafton county
let's say we're all in the same
delegation okay um
i don't have any more cards on this
particular bill is there anybody out in
the audience that has uh not handed in a
pink card for this would would matt be
willing to take a question
well he hasn't submitted anything uh
matt
are you willing to give any kind of uh
technical support on this particular
bill we've been just discussing
luno has one question quick compliance
question
very quick
and it actually relates to
representative lucas's
question on
on page one
beginning at line
five where where
we're enrolling as a full-time student
in the resident district
um
shall result in
the first part is immediate suspension
of payment of additional funds into the
student cfa
or mac oh he's filling out a card all
right
here i am reading it is even like uh and
he left
he's out of the building
okay i'm sorry no no that's all right
that's all right so um looking at um
looking at page one starting at line
five
where a student has has enrolled back in
their um in their
uh home uh resident um public school
and um
and current law says that that results
in the immediate suspension of payment
of additional funds
into the fa so that's state dollars
going into the efa
not not necessarily
withdrawals that you're making from the
efa
under current law that would be correct
to to to pay um uh
provider costs or
or something like that correct but um
but but i think um replicas brings up a
good point
uh what if um
what if uh um based on the the language
on lines 11 and 12
were to were to kick in
um
uh does um
does the scholarship organization
have any and and i think it might
even including this the lang the
proposed language have an ability to
encumber
um funds
once you get a request for reimbursement
even if that reimbursement hasn't been
made are you able to encumber funds
so that
you know if something intervening
happens like the student decides to go
to a public school
but you still owe the first semester
tuition bill for wherever they were
attending before i'm just making it up
um that you'd still be able to pay that
uh i think i mean this is a this is sort
of a technical issue in the weeds it's
an accounting in the weeds right i think
yeah so uh i think what we would do is
if if a student left the efa program to
return to their in-district public
school obviously the account would not
receive any more
public public funds because
as you said in statute they're that's
not allowable um so we would turn off
their ability to to get any more funds i
think that we could put a process in
place
where that account could be flagged
somehow um and then we we you know we
could we could work something out right
i think so
such as encumbering funds like what
well it's it's it's hard to know because
we wouldn't we wouldn't know okay right
what what what the cost would be um what
they would be spending those
funds on well i guess
you know
fault follow-up though but yes but but
those requests have already been put in
because they were subject to approval
by the scholarship organization upfront
certainly if they made the request prior
to exiting that's true absolutely right
that's all i'm saying made the request
prior to exiting and i think that would
then yeah that would be they would be
queued up in the system all right great
thank you very much
any further questions uh representative
baum
thank you mr chairman thank you matt
taking a question for example
following up on representative luna
a
tuition
payment has already been made to a
school
and it drops out halfway through
representative can you look for the
if a tuition payment has already been
made to the school
okay and the student drops out and goes
back to the public school halfway
through they're probably not going to be
any way of getting half of that tuition
payment correct
no there's probably not any way and any
refunds would come back to their efa
account not obviously not to the parents
yes representative porter thank you so
if someone was
um decided that they needed a
new computer as part of their
program homeschooled or whatever and
they put the uh
request in
those funds would be encumbered or
whatever they'd you'd say okay yeah you
can go get the computer and then a few
months later they drop out that
still
that would be paid for because it was
put in prior to
there
well assuming that they had the funds
and assuming that they had not purchased
a computer because administrative rules
you can only purchase one computer every
three years
uh then that would be considered an
allowable expense
okay thank you if they obviously if they
uh seen no further
questions thank you very much
and uh with that
so for all the committee members here
you might put down on your calendar that
everything's scheduled for the fourth
will be postponed
now we're supposed to get a real dozer
of a storm here
yeah
permee yes friday friday the fourth
um it looks like we got a storm coming
in some folks could get more than others
you know the other day you got a lot in
the south i got a half inch up in
haverhill
um
so but that we are going to reschedule
everything on the 4th to the 15th
same order same bills but just taking
them flopping them in on the 15th
so
there are four committees which had
bills scheduled for on friday um they're
all going to be you know
postponed because of storm we haven't
done that yet this year we've done it
other years many times
sometimes one person comes in for the
hearing conducts the hearing but that's
not fair for the people coming to
testify
the official notice hasn't gone out yet
you know i we're just putting that out
right now as i'm speaking
um so
so i would i would say yes
the house probably will not be meeting
here
mr chair do we do we know if we're
having a um it's
blabber mouth over here do you know if
we're having a session
that week
i had
written in my calendar yes we are yes we
are on the 16th it's half a day i don't
have the specific times but that's also
when the governor does his thing
and we have a joint on the 16th and then
let's see let me get my dates this is
the 15th
and the 7th the 17th we're having a
session
don't ask me the difficult questions
i uh i was asked by representative
porter are we doing 2016. yes
we have a half day on the 16th and a
full day on the 17th we're on the 16th
and the 17th
i don't know
on friday i would assume that criminal
justice education
make sure you come in
early
okay we've got about 10 minutes before
you
yes
okay i'm just for some clarification for
everybody here here's what's going on
a little bit more information
on the 16th
we will be starting in manchester
same place
but starting at one the gavel will drop
at one o'clock
will be a session day afternoon
trying to schedule the governor in for
the state of the state that will occur
sometime on the 17th
when we're also down in concord working
on bills
so that he's
manchester excuse manchester
on the 17th
so
we will be in manchester on the
afternoon of the 16th and again all day
on the 17th
the state of the state will be blended
in somewhere in on the 17th the day
prior to is when the governor has
governor and council meetings and so
there's a lot going on they're trying to
eighth in the morning
no
i i asked that question here i was
saying can we take you know do something
on the 16th you know get a couple bills
done no we can't because we're going to
be in manchester
and so you know unless and
but yeah
i i thought you know it'd be great to do
it but you know we can't
stop on the way but
no
so we're not going to be meeting on that
not the 18th that's correct now whether
or something gets put in what the 18th
of what friday
yeah uh i haven't looked at that week
i'm not looking at all those bills we
have yet to do and we have a lot of
stuff and we're going to have a lot of
bills coming up with a lot of debate
uh so we're going to have to start
scheduling that in i have set up so on
the 9th there will be
on the 9th we're going to have to exact
those 7 early bills which we have
remaining we had
what 16 early bills i think we thought
it was 15 we had one added on which i
wasn't aware of so we have 16 we we have
done nine of them so far we have seven
to go
and then
after we're done on the ninth those
early bills we'll start whittling down
that list
of the bills which i've
selected here
and i've given a copy to representative
cordelli and to representative luna
we're going to work down into that list
of bills to start executing
yes i haven't planned on that at this
point in time
um
i haven't you know i have to look at
that schedule here um
i have not i had not been planning to
exact we can exec anytime we wanted
exactly if we finished some
let's we have a hearing right now
after this hearing we'll get into some
of this discussion okay but we have
people here waiting i don't want to keep
them waiting as well we're also
streaming
so in looking at the calendar right now
we have one bill left today that's hb
1669.
that is uh requiring the department of
education to administer the education
freedom account program and 1669.
[Music]
bonnie hamm is here yes represent ham
that's another one of your bills um
representative bonnie ham lincoln
woodstock waterville
and i'm here to introduce and sponsor
house bill 1669 requiring the department
of education to administer the education
that wherever it says scholarship
organization
uh
department has been um inserted instead
um
and i feel strongly that
this a new program this is a new idea
and
going to become part of our overall
educational
opportunities that we offer students in
new hampshire
i feel strongly
that this needs to be administered by
the department of education
just as the department of education
oversees
public schools and other opportunities
i do not
support it
being
looked at separately over here
by a separate uh entity
that perhaps doesn't have the same focus
that what
i think this
idea this new idea needs
it needs to be looked at in conjunction
with the public school opportunities
we're now offering it's an alternative
it's another
opportunity for students
and i think it deserves
the department of education's oversight
along with that comes rulemaking along
with that comes
our involvement the legislative
involvement
it becomes more accountability
it's public money
it affects state and local
it it can potentially have an impact
on local schools
um and so i think we need to bring it in
house
i do not think that that this is an idea
that we should outsource
to someone else
to be responsible
to make all these decisions
i think the program
uh
could be administered
along the same lines as
envisioned
that there's applications for it
and there's qualifications needed
and so forth but
i just
don't see
it
becoming part
of our master plan
as readily
or as appropriately
perhaps as it needs to become part of
our overall education plan for our
students
for our communities
for our
state of new hampshire
and
um
in my mind
the same monies that perhaps
we are paying um
to have someone else administer this
program
can be
monies used to offset
the
additions we need
to
provide to the department of education
to perhaps oversee this
but i see so many advantages
to
it becoming part
of
the state of new hampshire's
education plan i think it i think it's
an idea that may
take off even better than
than we envisioned i think there may be
a good deal of interest in this
additional
opportunity
to custom tailor
the needs of each individual child
the public schools
do a good job in general
but
they
perhaps are not the
exact right program
for every child
i do not want to see
this program erode
what we're doing
for
the children in our public school
systems
i think we can't look at we can't look
at one without looking at the whole
overall
um
picture here so that's it in a nutshell
the accountability
the coordination
the efficiency
in my mind
is
far better
if we make it a priority most
departments when we take on a new idea
or a new program
that is a major program this is a major
program
i
are usually done in house
very rarely this is kind of an
exceptional thing
in my mind rarely
does
the department of environmental services
for instance or any department
i think it would be the same for any
department
sort of sub contract
in the private sector to try to develop
a state program
that's going to affect you can't look at
things in a vacuum
and that's it in a nutshell i
originally wrestled with
um
the education freedom account
concept i did
because i'm very very vested in my local
school district
and i worried worried worried
about what impact this would have
on
our local school
and i thought about it a lot and
i
just feel the majority of us wanted to
try this
the majority
of
us
said this idea is worthy
and therefore
the last thing in the world
i would want to do is to
to
repeal it or be negative about it i want
to be positive about it i want to give
it a chance and i hope it i hope it
totally exceeds my expectations
i hope i'm
about
how many people are going to be
interested in this
and what impact it's going to have
for the 30 out of 288 children let's say
in my district to enhance their
opportunity is a wonderful thing
a wonderful thing and if it can be done
so that it's not detrimental to the 158
left in the school building i'm all for
it i am absolutely all for it and i
think it can be done i think this is
going to be part of our overall
educational up this is just the
beginning
education needs reform we've been
a little stale
recently
in our town
and we need to look outside the box
and offer more opportunities
we want our children in new hampshire
to be successful
at whatever they want to do
and one size doesn't fit all
and whatever they're interested in i
want to be able to afford them that
opportunity
to
learn all about it and do it well
and contribute to our economy
and to our quality of life here and
that's in it in a nutshell
i want to make it be a good program and
i want it to get off to a very good
start
and i think
it has
more chance of doing that if it's within
the department of education
and it's within our overall master plan
for education you can tell i feel
strongly about it and and thank you very
much for hearing me out
thank you thank you very much uh
representative cordelia did you have
your hand up
yes thank you mr chairman uh thank you
for uh sticking around for this bill
also
um
i was just wondering in terms of
the legislation and the department of
education takeover of the program
do you feel
efa legislative oversight committee that
we have in place
and the
contract that
the department has put in place
with the children scholarship fund
are insufficient
to monitor the program
i
i think
that if we if we go that route
and i'm not saying it might work i'm not
i don't know i'm but i'm i'm i'm not as
confident
as
as i am
with the thought that if this is
studied if this is administered
and is part of the department of
education who has a mission
to provide an excellent education to all
our children
and looks at it in conjunction with
everything else out there that's being
offered
and has the oversight
of rulemaking and has the oversight of
the legislature and has the support
of the state of hampshire and the state
of new hampshire is backing it 100
percent
in my mind
it it
is apt to be
a better and more successful
program
you might
are you aware
that
three states with
existing education savings accounts
program
have reached out to children's
scholarship fund
to ask them to take over the operation
and administration of their state
programs
thank you very much for the question i
know nothing about i know nothing
about
the entity being proposed to administer
this is no reflection on them
whatsoever not at all not at all i know
nothing about them on purpose i didn't
look into
um
what they're about at all i just feel
strongly that
that this is an important part of what
the state of new hampshire does
provide
and encourage a good education and to me
it's important enough it's an important
enough mission
that we should
the state of new hampshire should give
it an awful lot of attention and backing
and oversight and
monitoring i just i just can't help but
think it would be
a better project
and more
uh we are
spending
um
taxpayers money local and state
we are we have a
a high responsibility
a fiduciary responsibility to do a good
job with those dollars and a good job
with the future of our children so i
can't help but thank
the department of education that's their
mission that's a goal
that's their expertise
i can't help but think
that's the place
this program this new startup program
thank you
further questions represent
thank you very much for taking my
question
good math it's hard to tell
um do you feel that uh the department of
education uh because of
its um
staff that has educational experience
and also they have legal experience on
the team with our attorney fenton who
shows up every day and
uh
got to get her a little jolt today and
um also you know the the accounting that
um the state department of education
does on a regular basis that that kind
of expertise
would be
invaluable to a program like this
i absolutely agree i absolutely agree
they're they're the best they're they're
they are the
experts on the topic we're not sending
it over to another department that knows
nothing about education
the department of education i would have
to think
knows has the expertise the knowledge
the expertise and should have the desire
to get this program
up and going and be a positive things
thing for the students of new hampshire
i agree
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question
are you aware that this committee exec
and passed 18-1 to be on the consent
calendar
house bill 1627
which is establishing an education
freedom account program administrator in
the department of education
thank you thank you for that yes i did
hear about that yes i did
and i was happy i was happy to see that
and i don't know if that's enough extra
staffing to do this maybe not
maybe that might be some technological
um technology uh equipment and so forth
needed i don't know but
i i was very happy that that that was
to me
a good start towards
supporting
educational opportunities
thank you uh reps and luna
thank you very much mr chair and thank
you again
ms ham representative for joining us
this afternoon and bringing this bill
forward
the the bill does have a a fiscal note
on it and turning to the uh
the back page there's not a lot of
information uh in the fiscal note
um uh other than uh the department sort
of wonders whether they would require to
build out a technology system and an rfp
and coordinate it with the department of
of information technology all of the do
it
part there
and
and that the bill provides neither an
appropriation nor authority for new
personnel
and and i guess it does this
um with the backdrop that the um the
education freedom account program
was uh was budgeted um not even a year
ago
at 129 000 and it's already up over 8.1
million dollars
so given the fact that it's already gone
over budget so much do you think that
the that the department would be able to
find the money to um
to uh to provide the implementation of
this and possibly even find that money
out of the 10 that the scholarship
organization retained so the out of the
8.1 million
um
in the program the scholarship
organization retains 810 000
um
for administrative costs um that that
the department may be able to find the
funds
thank you thank you for your question um
thank you and my answer is yes i mean
just that ten percent just that amount
is a good start
and it's going towards
um
education you know there isn't a
uh we're not outsourcing so there isn't
a management fee or something a profit
margin in there
that
that money would go a long ways towards
underwriting this program
and
the statistics you just
quoted
tells me
this program is going to take off
our restorations for the interest in it
were grossly underestimated
and so that's how important this program
is
this is not
going to be a little program
that helps 20 kids
in new hampshire or whatever
it is going to
challenge
the public school system
uh tremendously
and that that isn't a bad thing change
is inevitable um
and and it's always good to take
a second look at what you're doing it's
always good to
to
challenge the public schools
continue
to
improve their offering
because this indicates
the amount of interest and alternatives
to what we're doing right now i don't
think we can sit here and have
any idea for sure how far this is going
to go or whether this is just the
beginning of
additional educational opportunities for
children
i agree with you 100 percent
that we can find the money we need to
find the money to do the job right
it needs to be a priority there's very
little
that is more important than education
yes you may so thanks very much and and
thanks for taking um my follow-up
question so um would it be fair to say
then that that one of your concerns that
you just articulated and maybe one of
the intents of this bill
is also to make sure that all of our
taxpayer money is spent on educational
purposes and that as this program grows
beyond 8.1 million dollars to 20 million
dollars to 50 million dollars to 75
million dollars that we're not going to
be seeing 10 percent of that money
7.5 million dollars
um
going to uh costs not associated with
educating new hampshire's kids
that that is correct i i
i think this program is going to be a
huge success
i'm making i'm i i don't want to make
any
reflection on on whomever is interested
in managing this account not at all not
at all i just think
that we need to spend public dollars
very very wisely and this is
important project that we need to look
at
in conjunction with everything
else we're doing on the local level and
state level to educate our children
so i really believe
that the money
and the oversight
of the spending of that money
can be better
handled in-house
i really do
think uh that
in-house when your focus is
and your loyalty and your fiduciary
responsibility and everything
is to the state of new hampshire
and its towns and cities and
citizens and children
that's your focus
not just
running one program you got to look at
the bigger picture and i think this is
something that needs
that bigger picture
focus
great thank you thank you very much
representative cordelli
thank you um
i was just wondering if if you were
aware that um
based on data reported to the department
by school districts
uh the administrative costs for school
districts is 10
also
i know in my town it's much more than
that
i can tell you
having served on the
a school budget committee for well more
than 30 years probably
and just got off it
it's the cost to administer
a local school
um district
is enormous
enormous
it is a large figure and and our
particular our community
it is
conservatively
one-eighth
of the cost
to administer our
local uh school district and part of the
problem is there's only 288 kids
we're not big enough we could handle
twice as many kids and so therefore the
numbers would look better
but um
i i know it's it's quite costly to
administer
further questions representative tanner
uh thank you over here again
and
thanks for serving on the budget
committee i'm on one too and it's it's
quite a journey thank you um but as i
look at the school budget um and
probably you do too at our the school
that i'm working with our administrative
costs are high but it includes
transportation it includes the building
um you know the curriculum uh
the the budget with the with the town
and the school board the bond issues a
whole lot of other things that that just
the cfa program
uh would not entail i think is
certainly a fraction of probably what
the total costs are for schools would
you agree to that
um
yes in general our our school is is
quite an expensive operation um to to
fund we spend
um
roughly 9 million for 288 children so
the numbers i quoted you one-eighth was
just for the
strictly
superintendent principal
guidance
not transportation not teachers not
anything else
we're a unique situation because we're
small in size
but
it
i do know
that
the education budget
in our
municipalities is
larger than the town
we spend more on
on
the school than we do on everything else
in the town from sewer water highway
police fire
absolutely everything else it
it exceeds
what we're spending for for all our
representative woodcock
thank you chairman
good afternoon again representative pam
thank you and i appreciate this bill it
sounds extremely uh thank you forward
thinking i i just have a question on the
uh effective date
uh i don't look did you have a chance to
speak with d.o.e
uh let's assume in a positive uh that
this was passed did you have the chance
to speak with doe to see if the fact
that this could be ramped up in time for
july 1 or this just as a standard
placeholder date uh no i did not i did
not consult with them and that
probably is quite ambitious i would
think
that the effective date might
have to be beyond that
okay that's just a date we
we picked but
i agree uh
i don't think there's any way we can get
it done by
july 1.
thank you thank you
further further questions from the
committee
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you so very much for listening to me and
and giving me this opportunity thank you
thank you
are there any other pink cards for this
bill
i don't have any other pink cards up
here so we will close the hearing for
1669.
okay
represent hobson you had some questions
before we were on this remember we you
had some questions you were asking i
um
mr chair
that's marjorie over here
um is there any way that the public will
know
is it is the list of bills that we're
executing
available to the public i know when
you're printed in the calendar the
picking bills may just occur right after
we hear the bill or they can pop up at
any time um
what i'm trying to do is work with all
the people here knowing here's where
we're going
executive sessions are not for the
public
executive sessions are for this group
right here to make we've already had our
hearing every one of the bills we exec
has been heard
now there's occasion when we may ask for
some technical support during a exact
session that's not uncommon it's been
done by every chair that i can remember
working with but there again too
um
the the uh
the public
really has to give their input
on the hearing side but there are people
who are invested
in these issues and
curious as to when a decision is going
to be made and if if they don't know
when it's going to be
exact they they don't get an opportunity
to watch us doing that work and that's
quite possible seeing that so and that
will be quite possible this year or this
session as well we may get down after we
come back after the the first session
down in manchester
and get into some bills have a real hole
and we're just going to start executing
bills um that's the only way we're going
to get out of here and that's the only
time way we're going to get these 102
bills completed
by the 17th of march
it's going to slide on us very quickly
here
it's coming
so ralph
it looks like municipal county is going
to be on the ninth foot but it looks
like our bill's gonna be on the 15th
from
what we were supposed to do on friday
yeah what we're doing on friday we're
going to be doing on the 15th yeah we
got that so an email went out from
lindsay yeah we did have some conflicts
between various committees executing at
the same time with people having to be
in you know two places at the same time
i know that this is what county has just
put up well that's happening with
everybody here we have some folks on
your party over here in the party over
here where they're serving on double
committees
and then you get to executive session
and you're not absent so you can't have
a sub you got to be one place or the
other that's you know we got to address
that issue because book parties are
incurring that issue
and so uh we had that issue coming up in
the fourth year but it's been resolved
now by this
yeah
okay i guess we are done right now so um
catch y'all tomorrow
you